ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
FOR TUESDAY APRIL TWENTY
SEVENTH WE DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM
YET BUT WILL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE WE ALSO DON'T HAVE
ANY AUTHORS JUST YET. SO THAT
WAS THE OPPORTUNITY. BUT FIRST
OFF I NEED TO MENTION SOME OF
THE JOYSTICKS FOR THE HEARING
TODAY BECAUSE OF THE CONTINUED
STAY AT HOME ORDER AND THE NEED
FOR SOCIAL DISTANCING WE ARE
MAINTAINING DISTANCING HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM AS WELL AS
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITAL MASKS.
ARE REQUIRED. AND THAT MEANS
THAT THERE ARE LIMITED NUMBERS
OF FOLKS WHO CAN BE IN THIS
HEARING ROOM LIMITED STAFF AND
LIMITED. MEMBERS AS WELL AS
WITNESSES BUT WE DO HAVE A BIT
OF ROOM FOR SOME WITNESSES SO
IF YOU DO WANT TO SPEAK ON A
BILL. LET ME KNOW AS A BILL IS
BEING HEARD AND I'M VERY TO
COMEUP TO THE MICROPHONE TO BE
ABLE TO GIVE TESTIMONY. OTHER
THAN THAT WILL BE DOING MOST OF
OUR TESTIMONY REMOTELY. EITHER
IN THE WITNESS VIDEO ROOM. OR
ON THE TELEPHONE LINES. SO FOR
THOSE WHO ARE IN THE HEARING
ROOM INCOMING FOR TO THE MICRO
PLEASE DO NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. AND PLEASE MAINTAIN
DISTANCE. APPROPRIATE SOCIAL
DISTANCING. THROUGHOUT THE
HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITAL. WE HAVE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATIONS HERE AT THE
CAPITOL I THINK LOCATED ON THE
NORTH SIDE OF. THE CAPITAL THAT
IS AN OPPORTUNITY THE ABILITY
TO COME TO THE CAPITOL WITHOUT
COMING TO THE HEARING ROOM AND
PROVIDE SOME TESTIMONY. FOR
THOSE WHO ARE ON THE PHONE
THERE SHOULD BE A PHONE NUMBER
ON YOUR SCREEN THAT PHONE
NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. AGAIN THAT NUMBER EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN SHOULD BE ON
THE SCREEN AS WELL AS- ON THAT
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND TE
PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO OH TWO
AGAIN THAT'S. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR TWO OH TWO WHICH
SHOULD ALSO BE ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND ON YOUR SCREEN AT
THIS POINT MAKE SURE YOU'RE
CALLING IN WHEN THE BILL IS
CALLED TO BE HEARD AND THEN WE
CAN MAKE SURE THAT. THAT WE
WILL GIVE INSTRUCTIONS TO THE
OPERATOR TO GIVE INSTRUCTIONS
TO YOU ON HOW THEN TO TESTIFY
FOR WITNESSES THAT ARE
TESTIFYING SHOULD BE CONNECTED
WELL ENOUGH IN ADVANCE TO BE
IDENTIFIED AND PROVIDE THEIR
TESTIMONY. ALL RIGHT I WILL
ALSO NOTE THAT IT HASN'T BEEN
AN ISSUE IN THIS COMMITTEE BUT
IT HAS BEEN THROUGHOUT SOME OF
THE COMMITTEE SOME PROTESTS
WITH THE INTENT. OF STALLING OR
INTERRUPTING BUSINESS AND THAT
WILL NOT BE TOLERATED WILL BE
GIVEN A WARNING THIS IS A
WARNING AND IF THAT BEHAVIOR
HAPPENS TO ALSO BE GIVEN A
WARNING. AND YOU MAY BE CUT OFF
FROM THE PHONE LINE OR ASKED TO
LEAVE. THE HEARING ROOM WE'RE
HAVING TO TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
BUT NOT PUBLIC COMMENT THAT IS
INTENDED TO BE DISRUPTIVE. WE
ARE STILL WAITING FOR. AUTHORS.
AS WELL AS A QUORUM.
GARCIA
WELCOME WE WILL TAKE ITEM
NUMBER SIX AB.
THIRTEEN FORTY
ONE. OR POLITICS- THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I WANT TO I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALL THEIR HARD
WORK AND HELPING WITH THE
AMENDMENTS FOR AB THIRTEEN
FORTY ONE- AND- I THINK THE
CHAIR OR STRENGTHENING THE BILL
ON THESE. AMENDMENTS HAVE A
READY ACCEPTED THE AMENDMENTS
HELLO BUT I MEAN I FEEL
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU THANK YOU-
I'M CALLING ME TO THE TO VOTE
IN FAVOR THIS BILL BECAUSE
EATING DISORDERS ARE SERIOUS
PUBLIC HEALTH. PROBLEM
AFFECTING OUR YOUTH OF ALL
RACES ASUS- AGES AND GENDER
ACCORDING TO A TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN ARTICLE. PUBLISHED IN
THE NEW ENGLAND JOURNAL OF
MEDICINE CONSUMING DIETARY
SUPPLEMENT NEEDS TO TWENTY
THREE THOUSAND EMERGENCY ROOM
VISITS PER YEAR. IN THE US.
WELL CALIFORNIA'S AT THE
FOREFRONT OF REGULATIONS
CONCERNING WEIGHT LOSS DIETARY
SUPPLEMENTS AND DIET PILLS WE
CANNOT PROHIBIT THE SALE OF
THESE PRODUCTS TO MINORS.
DESPITE WHILE DOCUMENTED
DANGERS. ADDITIONALLY IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT THE
POTENTIAL DANGERS OF THESE
PRODUCTS AFFECT ALREADY
WONDERFUL COMMUNITIES. FOR
EXAMPLE WOMEN ARE TWO TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO USE WEIGHT LOSS
SUPPLEMENTS AND OVER THE
COUNTER THAT BILLS THAN MEN. I
THINK AN AMERICAN ATLANTIC
LATINO ADULTS ARE AT HIGHER
RISK OF USING WEIGHT LOSS
SUPPLEMENTS THAN WHITE ADULTS.
LONDON THINGS ARE 40% MORE
LIKELY TO USE OVER THE COUNTER
THAT BUILT IN WHITE JEANS I
KNOW THIS IS A COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE THE MOST HORRIBLE WHEN IT
COMES TO THESE PRODUCTS. NO
COMMUNITIES NEED ARE THAT THESE
COMMUNITY THEATRE PROTECTION
TODAY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
SEA I HAVE TWO WITNESSES
LISTED. DR JASON NAGATA UC
SANTA CRUZ DIVISION OF
ADOLESCENTS EDDIE ADOLESCENT
AND YOUNG ADULT MEDICINE. AND
KELLY WOO AND THEN I ALSO HAVE
S. BRYN AUSTIN WHO WAS ON
STANDBY FOR TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
DR NICK OUT ARE YOU WITH US.
HERE GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRPERSON STONE AN
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY ABOUT
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN FORTY
ONE. MY NAME IS DR DAYTON THE
GADA AND I'M A PEDIATRICIAN AND
FACULTY MEMBER AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO. I'M HERE TODAY TO
SHARE SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH
SUPPORTING ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE AND URGE YOU
TO VOTE IN FAVOR OF THIS
IMPORTANT FAIL. THE US WEIGHT
LOSS SUPPLEMENT INDUSTRY
GENERATE OVER TWO POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN AB ANNUAL
REVENUE. WE HAVE ALL THE NEEDS
PRODUCT AND LOCAL PHARMACIES
GROCERY STORES AND HEALTH FOOD
STORES. WHAT MANY PEOPLE DON'T
KNOW IS THAT WEIGHT LOSS
SUPPLEMENTS ARE NOT REVIEWED BY
THE FDA FOR SAFETY OR
EFFECTIVENESS BEFORE THE END
FOR THE MARKET. RESEARCH
AFFECTING THE COMPOSITION OF
THE SUPPLEMENT HAVE FOUND THAT
MANY ARE LACED WITH BANNED
SUBSTANCES PRESCRIPTION DRUGS.
STIMULANTS THEY'RE ALL RIGHT
AND OTHER TOXIC INGREDIENTS.
RIGOROUS SCIENTIFIC STUDY AFTER
STUDY HAS SHOWN BE PERFECTLY
COMPLEMENT THE POSE SERIOUS
HEALTH RISKS TO CONSUMERS. FOR
INSTANCE ONE RECENT SCIENTIFIC
STUDY FOUND THAT YOU'RE USING
WEIGHT LOSS SUPPLEMENT FOUR
THREE TIMES MORE LIKELY THAN
THOSE USING ORDINARY VITAMINS.
SEVERE MEDICAL HARM INCLUDING
HOSPITALIZATION DISABILITY AND
EVEN DEATH. OTHER THANK YOU
HAVE BEEN QUITE LOCKED UP
WOMEN'S WITH ORGAN FAILURE
HEART ATTACKS STROKES AND THAT.
HE ADMITS THAT SUPPLEMENT YOU
READ THE TWENTY THREE THOUSAND
EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS EVERY
YEAR WITH A QUARTER DUE TO
WEIGHT LOSS SUPPLEMENT ALONE.
THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS RECENTLY ISSUED A
REPORT STRONGLY CAUTIONING
AGAINST TEAMS YOU'VE BEEN
PRODUCT FOR ANY REASON. YOU CAN
USE OVER THE COUNTER TOPICAL
AND PILLS ARE SIX TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO BE DIAGNOSED WITH AN
EATING DISORDER THE NON USERS.
AS A PEDIATRICIAN SPECIALIZING
IN ADOLESCENT EATING DISORDERS.
I HAVE CARED FOR CATHOLIC YOUTH
IN THE BAY AREA REVIEWS WEIGHT
LOSS SUPPLEMENTS AND DIET
PILLS. DEVELOP EATING
DISORDERS. HE KEPT BECOME
CRITICALLY ILL AND REQUIRED
HOSPITALIZATION. THE NUMBER OF
TEENAGERS HOSPITALISED FOR
EATING DISORDER THAT YOU GET
THAT HAVE DOUBLED SINCE THE
START OF THE PANDEMIC. WE NEED
TO GET THESE DANGEROUS PRODUCTS
OUT OF THE HANDS OF OUR KIDS.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN FORTY
ONE GIVE CALIFORNIA LAWMAKER
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE ACTION
NOW TO PROTECT THEIR CHILDREN.
THIS BILL WOULD PREVENT THE
TAIL WEIGHT LOSS SUPPLEMENT
THAN OVER THE COUNTER DIET PILL
COMBINER. ADDITIONALLY WOULD
MOVE THE PRODUCT IN OPEN SHELF
BEHIND THE COUNTER JUST AS WE
HAVE DONE WITH OTHER RISKY
PRODUCTS LIKE CIGARETTES. I
URGE YOU TO VOTE IN SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTEEN FORTY ONE. YOU MUST
ACT NOW TO PROTECT THE CHILDREN
OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION. MISTER
CHAIRMAN- MY SECOND WITNESS.
HEALTH YOU AFFECTING SCHOOL
TAKING A TEST THAT'S NOT
AVAILABLE YET- OKAY OKAY SO
WILL NOW MOVE TO THOSE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT
FOR A BI THIRTEEN FORTY ONE IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY SITE. TWENTY SECOND.
OKAY I UNDERSTAND WE HAVE
SOMEONE IN THE WITNESS VIDEO
ROOM. IF YOU JUST SPEAK HE
SHOULD COME OUT. NO I GUESS NOT
OKAY OPERATE WITH YOU OVER THE
PHONE. SORRY I MISUNDERSTOOD
I'M TRYING TO THIRTY THREE IF
YOU WERE REFERRING TO THE
REALIGNMENT OF THIS IS BRIAN
AUSTIN. AS FOR AB ONE THREE
FOUR ONE YES. OKAY I THINK YOU
I'M AVAILABLE HERE AS AN EXPERT
RIGHT. OKAY. THANK YOU GOOD TO
KNOW YOU'RE THERE IF WE HAVE
QUESTIONS. WE WILL. GETTY DID
YOU HAVE TESTIMONY THE WANTED
TO GIVE I HAVE MY NOTE HERE IS
THAT YOUR HE THAT YOU'RE HERE
FOR TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
EXACTLY YES- KELCIE WILLIS
TAKING  TEST SIXTEEN YEAR OLD-
IN DIAMOND BAR BUT SHALL JOIN
US AS SOON AS SHE'S OUT OF HER
CAST. COULD TESTIFY SORRY TO
INTERRUPT. OKAY OPERATOR THEN
WOULD YOU OPEN THE PHONE LINES
FOR THOSE WHO'D LIKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR AB
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE. WE'LL TAKE
NAME AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT
FOR A BI THIRTEEN FORTY ONE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR A BI
ONE THREE FOUR ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN THEY'RE OUT THIS TIME.
PLEASE ALTOGETHER LAMBERT'S.
OKAY. FIRST ALLIED FIFTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE FIFTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. HEARING NOTHING WE WILL
GO TO LINE FIFTY NINE ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. NINE FIFTEEN
MILLION UNDER FULLER. HI MY
NAME IS AMANDA REFLECTING THE
STRATEGIC TRAINING INITIATIVES
FOR THE PREVENTION OF EATING
DISORDERS AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. WE WILL
MOVE NEXT TO LINE SIXTY ONE ONE
MOMENT WHILE I OPEN YOUR LINE
PLEASE. GO AHEAD PLEASE. HI MY
NAME IS DEVELOPMENTS ARE NOT
THAT AND I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF. THIS BILL. THANK YOU. LOCAL
GO TO LINE FIFTY SEVEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
ARGHA MASH FROM INTERNATIONAL
SOCIOECONOMIC SABAR TORY I'M
STRONGER IN SUPPORT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA THIRTEEN FORTY ONE
DOLLAR. WE'LL GO NEXT TO LINE
FIFTY EIGHT GO AHEAD PLEASE.
HELLO MY NAME IS JULIE AND I
AGREE ON OPEN THE STRATEGIC
TRAINING INITIATIVES FOR THE
PREVENTION OF EATING DISORDERS
HI I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE. WE'LL GO TO
LINE SIXTY TWO GO AHEAD PLEASE.
HELLO MY NAME IS ALAN SHEARER
FROM THE INTERNATIONAL
SOCIOECONOMICS ABOARD TORY AND
WE ARE IN FULL SUPPORT OF AB.
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE. THEN WE
HAVE NO OTHER LINES INTO AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU TO ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO WANTED
TO. IN HIS SUPPORT FOR A BI
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE. ALL RIGHT
SAY NONE WE WILL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION I HAVE TO OPPOSITION
WITNESSES KYLE TURK OF THE
NATIONAL NATURAL PRODUCTS
ASSOCIATION. AND LARISSA
SUSPENDISSE. FROM THE AMERICAN
HERBAL PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION MR
TURK I UNDERSTAND ARE YOU IN
THE VIDEO CONFERENCE ROOM. I'M
ON THE TELEPHONE ON THE
TELEPHONE OKAY GO AHEAD PLEASE.
THANK YOU- THE NATURAL PRODUCTS
ASSOCIATION IS THE OLDEST AND
LARGEST TRADE ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING MORE THAN SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MEMBERS
NATIONWIDE. WE IN OUR MEMBERS
MANY OF WHICH YOU HEARD FROM
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB THIRTEEN
FORTY ONE MEMBERS OF NPA AND
OTHERS LESS SIGNIFICANT
RESOURCES TO ENSURE THEIR
PRODUCTS ARE STATE. THESE
INCLUDE GOOD MANUFACTURING
PRACTICES RENDON PRODUCT
TESTING AND HEARING SOME
MARKETING GUIDELINES AND
FOLLOWING THE STRICT RULES AND
REGULATIONS THE FDA AND FTC
HAVE MADE FOR TWENTY FIVE
YEARS. THOSE RULES ENSURE THAT
THE UNITED STATES ENJOYED THE
STATE THIS DIETARY SUPPLEMENT
SUPPLY IN THE WORLD. AS WRITTEN
AB THIRTEEN FORTY ONE PROHIBITS
AND GREETINGS FROM BEING SOLD
TO MINORS UNDER THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN INCLUDING THERMOGENIC
AND LOOK TROPICS. THAT WOULD
MEAN SCHOOL LUNCHES EGGMAN
OFTEN. DECENT STEAK. AND OTHER
COMMON FOOD PRODUCTS SUDDENLY
BECOME CONTRABAND. AND IN OUR
VIEW IT'S RIDICULOUS TO PUT
THESE BUILDING BLOCKS OF
NUTRITION IN THE SAME CATEGORY
AS ALCOHOL AND TOBACCO. THIS
LEGISLATION APPEARS TO BE IN. A
SOLUTION IN SEARCH OF A PROBLEM
HOWEVER THERE IS NO PROBLEM
BECAUSE THERE IS NO EVIDENCE OF
A LINKAGE BETWEEN DIETARY
SUPPLEMENTS AND EATING
DISORDERS. HOW DO WE KNOW THAT
IT'S BECAUSE WE ASK. IN TWENTY
NINETEEN WE SUBMITTED A FOIA TO
THE FDA TO EXPLORE. WHETHER
THERE WERE ANY ADVERSE EVENTS
FROM CASES INVOLVING EATING
DISORDERS AND DIETARY
SUPPLEMENTS. THE ANSWER FROM
THE FDA'S NO LINKAGE BETWEEN
EATING DISORDERS AND
SUPPLEMENTS. IF AB THIRTEEN
FORTY ONE WERE TO BECOME LAW
MANY PRODUCTS SUCH AS VITAMIN
D. AND CALCIUM WOULD NOT BE
MADE AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE UNDER
EIGHTEEN AND THIS WOULD BE A
CATASTROPHIC IMPACT ON
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES USING IS
A CENTRAL PRODUCTS TO
SUPPLEMENT THEIR HEALTH AND GET
THE CRITICAL NUTRIENTS THEY
NEED. BY PUTTING THESE
SUPPLEMENTS BEHIND THE COUNTER
THE BILL WOULD FURTHER
STIGMATIZE THOSE FIGHTING
WEIGHT MANAGEMENT ISSUES WHO
ALREADY FACE A RANGE OF MENTAL
AND PHYSICAL HEALTH CHALLENGES.
AND EXCELLING SAFE DIETARY
SUPPLEMENTS SHOULD NOT BE A
CRIMINAL OFFENSE YEAH UNDER
THIS BILL- THE FINE FOR SELLING
NUTRITIONAL SUPPLEMENTS WOULD
BE FOUR TO FIVE TIMES HIGHER
THAN THE FINES FOR SELLING
ALCOHOL OR TOBACCO TO A MINOR.
IF AB THIRTEEN FORTY ONE PASSES
IT WOULD CRIMINALIZE THE SALE
OF PRODUCTS LIKE WHEY PROTEIN
AND AMINO ACIDS. BUT BEYOND THE
ABSURDITY OF TREATING HEALTHY
AND NUTRITIONAL INGREDIENTS
LIKE A PUBLIC ENEMY THERE'S A
BROADER ECONOMIC IMPACTS TO
CONSIDER IN CALIFORNIA THE
NATURAL PRODUCTS INDUSTRY
SUPPORTS OVER FIFTY THOUSAND
JOBS BUT IT WOULDN'T JUST BE
SUPPLEMENT STORES GROCERY
STORES RESTAURANTS AND OTHERS
WOULD ALSO POTENTIALLY BECOME
VICTIMS WHY WE BELIEVE. WHICH
IS WHY WE BELIEVE THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT LEGAL CHALLENGES
FOR THIS BILL. WE SUPPORT THE
EFFORTS TO STOP ILLEGAL DRUGS
MASQUERADING AS NATURAL
PRODUCTS BEING SOLD TO
CONSUMERS AND ESPECIALLY TO
MINORS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
HAS VASTLY FORSMAN POWERS AND
HAS A LONG TRACK RECORD OF
PUNISHING CRIMINALS WHO BREAK
THE LAW. MPA SUPPORTS VIGOROUS
ENFORCEMENT OF THE LAW TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS BILL THIS
LEGISLATION WILL NOT ACCOMPLISH
THAT WILL WORK AGAINST THE
EXISTING LAW THAT IS WELL
DESIGNED TO PROTECT THE MORE
THAN THREE IN FOUR AMERICANS TO
USE A NUTRITIONAL SUPPLEMENT.
THANK YOU AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU.
THEN I HAVE A RECESSES BUTTONS.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS LAWRENCE
THE FACT THAT AS WITH MILLER'S
FACT THAT IT'S AN ASSOCIATE AND
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN HERBAL PRODUCTS
ASSOCIATION. WELL WE SUPPORT
THE ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S GOAL OF
ATTRACTING THIS SERIOUS PUBLIC
HEALTH PROBLEM OF EATING
DISORDERS AMONG YEARS. WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPONENT EP
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE. ALTHOUGH
THE BILL IS WELL INTENTIONED IT
WAS ONLY TO SCAPEGOAT DIETARY
SUPPLEMENT PRODUCTS WITHOUT
ACTUALLY EDUCATING THE TEAM. TO
HELP. FIRST AS PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED DIETARY SUPPLEMENTS
ARE SUBJECT TO WELL ESTABLISHED
DIRECT REGULATION ENFORCEMENT
TEAM THE FDA FTC BOTH HAVE
CLEAR AUTHORITY ALREADY DIETARY
SUPPLEMENT THROUGH THE FEDERAL
FOOD DRUG COSMETIC ACT AND THE
FTC ACT. THE FDA AND CHARGED
WITH INSPECTING MANUFACTURING
FACILITIES REVIEWING LABELING
AND MONITORING PRODUCTS FOR
SAFETY WELL THE FCC IN EFFECT
OF FALSE AND MISLEADING
ADVERTISING. IT'S A FACT
CONTRADICTS THE FATHER'S
ARGUMENTS THAT THESE PRODUCTS
ARE IMMACULATE CLIP IN
ADEQUATELY REGULATED FOR THEIR
ADVERTISING. IS FALSE AND
MISLEADING. SECOND IT DIDN'T TO
NOTE THE GUY STUFF CAN
INGREDIENTS CITED BY THE
DOCTORS. SUCH AS THE FEDERAL
AND PHARMACEUTICAL. ARE BANNED
FROM SALE BY THE FDA AND ARE
THEREFORE ALREADY ILLEGAL.
LASTLY THE EXTENT THAT
REASONABLE MINDS MIGHT DISAGREE
ON THE UTILITY OF THESE
PRODUCTS BUT I THINK WE CAN ALL
AGREE THAT THE PROPER PRODUCT
AND IT'S THE HARSHEST FORM OF
PRODUCT REGULATION. AND SHOULD
THEREFORE BE AFFIRMATIVELY
SUPPORTED BY EVIDENCE. INDICATE
THE EVIDENCE SHOULD SHOW A
CORRELATION BETWEEN THESE
PRODUCTS AND EATING DISORDERS
BODY DYSMORPHIC DISORDER. WE
HAVE THAT QUESTION WHETHER THIS
STUDY CITED THE RECTIFIED BONTA
PROVIDED EVIDENCE. A REVIEW OF
THE REFERENCE DATE. PROVIDED
SHOWS THAT YOU HAVE THREE
IDENTIFIED THAT HE DID NOT
ACTUALLY EVALUATE MEATLOAF
PRODUCTS ARE PRESENT EVIDENCE
THAT THESE PRODUCTS ARE
FREQUENTLY USED BY TEENS- AT
LEAST LEVELS BEYOND MANUFACTURE
RECOMMENDATION. UNFORTUNATELY
THE OWNER AT THE END OF THE
BILL AND TO BROADEN THE PRODUCT
THAT COVERS. INCLUDING SOME
THAT WE THINK WOULD BE
INADVERTENTLY COVERED IT'D
BROAD DEFINITIONS IN THE BILL.
WILL LEAD TO UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES INCLUDING PUSHING
CONSUMERS TO PURCHASE PRODUCTS
FROM DUBIOUS FELLERS IN ONLINE
MARKETPLACES WHERE THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THESE ADULTERATED
PRODUCTS ARE SOLD. FOR THESE
REASONS MUST RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE AB THIRTEEN FORTY ONE.
WE GREATLY APPRECIATE THE AFTER
MEDIAN ACCOUNT. AND WE ARE
COMMITTED TO AN ONGOING
DIALOGUE WITH THE AUTHOR SHOULD
THE BILL MOVED OUT OF COMMITTEE
TODAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE OUR
COMMON. THANK YOU. RIGHT IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY SIDE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO INDICATE OPPOSITION TO AB
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE. SEEING NONE
ABOUT THOUGH WITH HIS VIDEO
ROOM. ALL RIGHTS AND THEN
ANYBODY HERE IN. THE HEARING
ROOM WHO'D LIKE TO INDICATE
OPPOSITION AB THIRTEEN FORTY
ONE. SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD
YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTEEN FORTY
ONE. THANK YOU AND IF YOU ARE
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION TO AB
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME AN
EIGHTEEN T. SPECIALIST WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND YOU WILL WAIT TO BE
CALLED AT THAT TIME. WILL OPEN
UP LINE SIXTY FOUR GO AHEAD
PLEASE. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS- DON GILBERT ON BEHALF
OF THE CONSUMER HEALTHCARE
PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION WERE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANKS.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A COUPLE
MORE IN Q. ONE MOMENT WHILE WE
PROVIDE THEM THEIR LINE NUMBERS.
WE'LL GO TO LINE FIFTY SIX
QUIET PLACE. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TATUM ACLERIS
DANCE MADE BY THOSE ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNCIL FOR RESPONSIBLE
NUTRITION IN OPPOSITION TO AB
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE IT WOULD
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS BUT THAT OF
THE REST OF THE ACCIDENT AND
APPRECIATE THE ONGOING DIALOGUE
WITH THE AUTHOR. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE
LOWER L. SECURE AT THIS TIME. I
THANK YOU I WILL BRING IT. BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE. EFFORT SO I'D
LIKE TO START WITH A QUORUM
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE
HERE. GALLAGHER CHAU CHIU
DAVIES. GONZALEZ HOLDEN KALRA
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN REYES. THANK
YOU WE DO HAVE A QUORUM ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FOR THE AUTHOR. THE
DALLAS FIRST I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL WE
HAD A BRIEF INTERPLATE OUT
YESTERDAY- I AM ASTONISHED BY
THE OPPOSITION WITNESS THE
FIRST OPPOSITION MIGHT MISS- AS
I THINK A LOT OF WOMEN- AND
IMPROBABLY MEN TOO BUT WOMEN IN
PARTICULAR COULD TELL YOU. THE
LACK OF RESEARCH OR DATA THAT
LINKS A NUMBER OF DIETARY
SUPPLEMENTS WITH IN DISORDERS
HASN'T BEEN ADEQUATELY EXPLORED
IN BUT COMMONSENSE AND ALL OF
OUR EXPERIENCES CAN TELL YOU
THAT THERE IS A LINK AND THAT
THERE IS A DROP FOR YOUNG
WOMEN- IN MY DISCUSSIONS WITH
YOUR TOLD YOU I DON'T THINK
YOUR BILL GOES FAR ENOUGH I
WOULD ALSO- ASKED THAT IN THE
FUTURE WE LOOK AT POSSIBLY
TAKING WATER PILLS AND
LAXATIVES OFF OF THE OVER THE
COUNTER- OPPORTUNITIES FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE TO PURCHASE. AS
THEY ARE GATEWAYS INTO HERBAL
SUPPLEMENTS THAT ARE DANGEROUS
THEY ARE IN THEMSELVES
DANGEROUS TO YOUNG WOMEN. AND
SO AT I THINK THAT THIS ISSUE
IN THE EXPLORATION OF THIS
ISSUE IS WAIT PASSED OVER TO-
I'M SO GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE
TAKING IT OUT IT'S DIFFICULT
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT WORK AND-
YOU KNOW HOW. WHEN WE WERE
YOUNGER NOT THAT WE'RE NOT
ANYMORE- BUT THERE WAS A BROAD
DISCUSSION ABOUT ALL THE AFTER
SCHOOL SPECIALS THAT BASICALLY
GAVE US A ROADMAP TO BECOMING-
GAMINI DISORDERS TO BE QUITE
HONEST. IN AND WE KNOW THAT A
LOT OF THEM START A LOT OF THE
REALLY DESTRUCTIVE BEHAVIOR
STARTS WITH- WHAT IS LESS
DESTRUCTIVE I. THOUGHT TO BE
LESS DISTRACTED BY GIRLS WHICH
IS THE TAKING OF OVER THE
COUNTER MEDICATION- THAT WOULD
LEAD TO THE SOUTH I WANT TO
THANK YOU WHEN APPLIED YOU ARE.
GOING TO ASK YOU AND BY YOU IN
YOUR SPONSORS TO THINK ABOUT IF
NOT THIS YEAR IN THE FUTURE XP
I MEAN THAT'S BECAUSE- FROM MY
EXPERIENCE EXPERIENCE OF THOSE
AROUND ME IT ALL STARTS WITH
WATER PILLS MOST ON THE
LAXATIVES MIXON TO THIS SO-
THERE'S MORE WORK TO BE DONE
BUT THANK YOU FOR THIS FIRST
STEP AND I'M I'M- GOING TO BE
JOINING YOU AS A JOINT AUTHORS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. RIGHT C.
NONE MAY CLOSE AT YES I DO WANT
TO QUICKLY ADDRESS SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION I DON'T APPRECIATE
THE MISINFORMATION- CAMPAIGN
THAT'S OUT THERE ANYWAY
PRODUCTS FOR EXAMPLE ARE SOLD
AS FOOD AND HAVE- NUTRITION
FACT LABELS ON THE BACK OF
PACKAGES SO THEY WOULD NOT BE
COVERED BY AB THIRTEEN FORTY
ONE IF THEY'RE BEING SOLD
SPECIFICALLY AS DIET
SUPPLEMENTS THEY WOULD BE
COVERED OUT THERE BUT THE
REALITY IS THAT THESE YOUNG.
CHILDREN PIC THAT THESE
HABITATS KIDS IN CARRY THEM
INTO ADULTHOOD AND WE HAVE THEM
FOR A LIFETIME NOT JUST THE BAD
HABITS THAT AFFECT THE HEALTH
PHYSICALLY BUT MENTALLY- AND WE
HAVE SEEN DURING THIS PANDEMIC
HAS GOTTEN WORSE FOR CHILDREN
OUT THERE AS A BEING BOMBARDED
WITH IMAGES ON A REGULAR BASIS
AS THE FORTY FOUR YEAR OLD
WOMAN. THOSE IDEAS STILL
STIGMATIZED ARE STILL WITH ME
TODAY AND SO WHILE WE WORK
EVERY DAY TO BE THE STRONG
WOMAN THAT WE WANT THE PUBLIC
TO SEE S. VERY ALITY IS THAT WE
NEVER STOP AT WORK AND SO THIS
IS NOT JUST ABOUT THE PHYSICAL
HEALTH- AND COMMON SENSE BUT
ABOUT THE MENTAL HEALTH ABOUT
PROTECTING OUR CHILDREN OUT
THERE AND SO I'M A LITTLE
OFFENDED BY OUR FIRST WITNESS
OUT THERE. LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE SOMETHING
THAT IS FAIR I AND I AGREE WITH
MS GONZALEZ THAT WE SHOULD BE
DOING MORE BUT THIS IS A GOOD
FIRST STEP. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHEN I WROTE. THANK YOU WE DO
HAVE A INTENSE. THAT MY IS DUE.
AS AMENDED APPROVE. CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER NO CHAU.
CHIU DAVIES. DAVIS KNOW
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I HOLDEN
KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY KILEY NO
MAIENSCHEIN REYES RACE I. THANK
YOU. THE BILL IS ON CALL. NEEDS
I THINK FOR MORE VOTES WAS THE
INDICATION ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
THEN WILL MOVE TO ITEM NO WELL
LET'S CONNECTICUT A MOTION ON
THE CONSENT AGENDA FIRST. OKAY
MOTION AND SECOND ON THE
CONSENT AGENDA. AS MISS AMERICA
HAND COMES UP. KALRA PLEASE
STONE AYE STONE AYE GALLAGHER.
IS CONSENT GALLAGHER AYE CHAU
CHIU DAVIES DAVIES I GONZALEZ
CONSOLES I HOLDEN KALRA. KALRA
AYE KILEY KELLY I MAIENSCHEIN
REYES FIVE RECYCLE THOSE ARE
OUT THAT IS A V. SIX ONE EIGHT
CHOI. A. B. SIX SIX TWO
RODRIGUEZ A. B. TEN NINETY FOUR
ARAMBULA AND AB THIRTEEN FORTY
NINE MATHIS. RIGHT WILL MOVE TO
ITEM NUMBER ONE A. B. TEN
THIRTY THREE AM IS BARKING.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
FIRST I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
WORK ON THIS BILL ANYONE EXCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. TO
THEIR PRESENT AB TEN THIRTY
THREE A BILL THAT WOULD REQUIRE
REMEDIATION BE THE FIRST STEP
IN EMPLOYEE SMALL EMPLOYER
DISAGREEMENTS ON PAID FAMILY
LEAVE. SAVING TIME FOR QUICKER
RESOLUTION AND MONEY ON COSTLY
LITIGATION LAST YEAR WE PASSED
SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE BY
SENATOR HANNAH BETH JACKSON. SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE EXPANDED
THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY RIGHTS
ACT SO THAT IT NOW APPLIES TO
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESSES WE
JUST FIVE OR MORE EMPLOYEES.
DUE TO CONCERNS ABOUT COSTLY
LITIGATION AND SMALL BUSINESSES
ABILITY TO COMPLY WITH THE NEW
MANDATE THE LEGISLATURE
ESTABLISH THE SMALL EMPLOYER
FAMILY LEAVE MEDIATION PILOT
PROGRAM IN BUDGET BILL AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN. THE
PROGRAM HAS A SUNSET DATE OF
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR. AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN WITH
A DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING CHARGES BEEN FILED.
FOR VIOLATION OF CIFRA AGAINST
AN EMPLOYER WITH FIVE TO
NINETEEN EMPLOYEES. THE
EMPLOYEE OR EMPLOYER WOULD NEED
TO REQUEST MEDIATION WITHIN
THIRTY DAYS OF RECEIVING A COPY
OF THE RIGHT TO SUE NOTICE. THE
PROBLEM IS THAT EMPLOYERS DON'T
RECEIVE A COPY OF THE RIGHT TO
SUE NOTICE UNTIL AFTER LAWSUIT
HAS BEEN FILED. UNDERMINING THE
PURPOSE OF THIS PROGRAM. THIS
IS FOR GOOD REASON WE DON'T
WANT THE EMPLOYER TO RECEIVE
THE RIGHT TO SUE NOTICE IF THE
EMPLOYEE NEVER DECIDES TO FILE
A LAWSUIT. AB TEN THIRTY THREE
CORRECT THE ISSUE BY HAVING THE
EMPLOYEE CONTACT DFG AGES
MEDIATION PROGRAM. IF THEY
DECIDE THEY DO WANT TO PROCEED
WITH THE LAWSUIT. THE DFG H.
WILL THEN CONTACT THE EMPLOYER
TO ARRANGE MEDIATION WITHIN THE
NEXT SIXTY DAYS. IF BOTH
PARTIES AGREE MEDIATION WOULD
BE FRUITLESS THEY NEED NOT
PARTICIPATE. SECONDLY THE BILL
CLARIFIES EDIFICATION OF AND
SUBJECT TO MEDIATION UNDER THE
PROGRAM BUT WAS NOT THE
EMPLOYER CAN. EIGHT TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF ASHLEY HOFFMAN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN KEVIN MCCARTY WITH
NFIB. THANK YOU I DO HAVE THOSE
TWO WITNESSES LISTED IS WITH US
ON THE TELEPHONE ACTUALLY
HOFFMAN AND KEVIN PICTURE ID.
THE SOFTWARE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS WITH IS
ACTUALLY HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AT MOUNT SPONSOR AT
EIGHTY AND THIRTY THREE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER NOTED- AT TEN
THIRTY THREE CLEAN SEVEN
ALREADY EXISTING MEDIATION
PROGRAM AT THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED LAST YEAR WHEN SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE WAS BEING
DISCUSSED ABOUT EXPANDING
CALIFORNIA FAMILY RIGHTS ACT
SMALL BUSINESSES WHO JUST FIVE
EMPLOYEES THERE WAS SOME
CONCERN ABOUT POTENTIAL
LITIGATION AS A SMALL
BUSINESSES LEARN TO IMPLEMENT
THE FROCKS WHICH COMES WITH
QUITE A BIT OF WINKING COMPLEX
REGULATION AND- AN AGREEMENT
WAS THEREFORE MADE TO CREATE
THIS MEDIATION PROGRAM. THROUGH
THE EIGHT UNDER THAT PROGRAM IF
THEY SEE HER COMPLAINTS FILED
AGAINST THE SMALL BUSINESS WITH
FEWER THAN TWENTY EMPLOYEES
EITHER PARTY COULD REQUEST THE
PARTY CERTAIN MEDIATE THE CLAIM.
THAT THE FCC HAS GREAT
MEDIATION PROGRAM OF THE ISSUE
WITH THE CURRENT LANGUAGES
STATED IS THAT IN ORDER TO
REQUEST MEDIATION THE EMPLOYER
MUST REQUEST THAT WITHIN THIRTY
DAYS OF RECEIVING A RIGHT TO
SUE NOTICE. HOWEVER BECAUSE AN
EMPLOYER IS NOT ACTUALLY SERVED
WITH A COPY OF THAT OFTENTIMES
THE PLAYERS DO NOT RECEIVE A
COPY OR EVEN SEE IT UNTIL
LITIGATION HAS STARTED OFTEN
WELL AS THE DISCOVERY PROCESS.
SO IN PRACTICE EMPLOYERS UNABLE
TO UTILIZE THIS PROGRAM VIDEO
FEEDS HAS CONFIRMED THAT AN
ACQUAINTANCE SAYS WHERE THE
PROGRAM HAS BEEN USED AS FAR
SINCE JANUARY FIRST IT'S ALWAYS
BEEN THE EMPLOYEE THAT HAS
REQUESTED MEDIATION- EVEN TEN
THIRTY THREE ADDRESSES THIS BY
PROVIDING THAT WHEN AN EMPLOYEE
DECIDES TO MOVE FORWARD THE
LAWSUIT THEY WILL CONTACT. THE
AT THE AGES DISPUTE RESOLUTION
PROGRAM THIS IS THE OFFICIAL
THEN REACH OUT TO THE EMPLOYER
AS LONG AS EITHER THE EMPLOYER
OR THE EMPLOYEE DOES WANT
MEDIATION I REQUEST THAT THE
DFU TOOL THAN A RAIN CHECK. IF
NEITHER PARTY REQUEST MEDIATION
THE EMPLOYER. THREE TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH FILING A LOT. THE
BILL ALSO KERR THAT ATTACKING
ERROR FROM A SPEAKER EIGHTY
LAST YEAR. BY ADDING PAYER IN
LAW. I SECRET A FAMILY MEMBER
THAT EMPLOYEE CAN QUICKLY TO
CARE. I WE JUST WANT TO THANK
THE- ARE. AND THE COMMITTEE AS
WELL AS FEEL AS LEGAL AID AT
WORK AND THAT APART APPARENTLY
HOW- ALL OF US. HAVE HAD AT OF
MEETINGS TRY TO. WORK THIS BILL
INTO A IT IS TO MAKE IT BETTER
FOR BOTH EMPLOYERS AND- I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY. YOU MAY
ABOUT THE EVENT- THAT THE
COMMITTEE HAS THE EFFORTS.
TODAY WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. FOR DROPPING. YES HI GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- KEVIN
MCCARTY ON BEHALF OF NFIB. WE
REPRESENT- PROXIMALLY FIFTEEN
THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESSES AND
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. MANY
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE STILL
SUFFERING FROM THE RESULT OF
COBIT. SMALL BUSINESSES DO NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO HUMAN RESOURCE
PERSONNEL OR LEGAL COUNSEL IN
THE SAME WAY OTHER LARGE
BUSINESSES. IN THE CALIFORNIA
FAMILY RIGHTS ACT WAS EXPANDED
LAST YEAR. SMALL BUSINESSES HAD
TO LEARN A NEW COMPLEX SET OF
REGULATIONS ON HOW TO PROPERLY
ADMINISTER. TRACK AND DOCUMENT
THAT LEAVE. DUE TO THE HIGH
RISK OF INADVERTENT ERRORS THAT
CAN BE MADE A SMALL EMPLOYERS
LEARN THIS NEW LEAVE PROGRAM.
AND THE FINANCIAL IMPACT. EVEN
ONE LAWSUIT CAN HAVE ON A
BUSINESS. THE SMALL EMPLOYER
FAMILY LEAVE MEDIATION PROGRAM.
IS IMPORTANT TO THE SMALL
BUSINESS COMMUNITY. AB TEN
THIRTY THREE ENSURES EMPLOYERS
ARE ACTUALLY ABLETO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE PROGRAM BY
FIXING THE WAY THAT THE
MEDIATION IS INITIATED UNDER
THE PROGRAM. WE OCCURRED YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB TEN THIRTY THREE
AND- THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE HERE
IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
TEN THIRTY THREE AT THE
MICROPHONE. YES MISTER CHAIRMAN
WORST CHRISTMAS CEILIDH ON
BEHALF OF THE HOLLYWOOD CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE. THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE IN THE HEARING ROOM. I SEE
NONE IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY SITE. SEEING
NONE OF THE WITNESS VIDEO ROOM.
SEEING NONE RIGHT OPERATOR
WHICH OPEN THE LINES FOR THOSE
WHO'D LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT
FOR A BI TEN THIRTY THREE. Q.
IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT
IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN THIRTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. BORDERLINE
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS DILLON
GIVEN THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU RYAN SIXTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING KATIE HANSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU WE WILL MOVED
OUT OPPOSITION I DO NOT HAVE
ANY OPPOSITION INDICATED THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM WOULD LIKE
TO INDICATE OPPOSITION. C. NONE
OF THE REMOTE TESTIMONY SITE.
SEEING NONE HOW ABOUT A FREE
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
ANY OPPOSITION TO AB TEN THIRTY
THREE. IF YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO AB TEN
THIRTY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
BRING YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS MR
GALLAGHER. YES WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING FOR THE
BILL'S VERY GOOD SMALL BUSINESS
SMALL BUSINESS FROM THE BILL-
AND I THINK. YOU KNOW IT'S- ONE
GETTING THE NOTICE I THINK IS
REALLY IMPORTANT BUT THEN ALSO
JUST HAVING THIS MEDIATION
PROCESS THAT COULD HELP
RESOLVE. DISPUTES BEFORE THEY
GO THROUGH. YOUR PROTRACTED
LITIGATION- SO. SHE TO WORK ON
THIS AND I THINK IT'S A GOOD
GOOD MEASURES WILL BE REALLY
HELPFUL SO. I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THANK YOU MR GALLAGHER IS
DAVIES THANK YOU I DO WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR MUCH YOU KNOW FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD
ESPECIALLY RIGHT NOW WITH THE
SMALL BUSINESSES AND- AND- YOU
KNOW THE- DEVASTATION THEY FELT
FOR THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF.
AND SO I'LL BE SUPPORTING AND-
WOULD LOVE TO BE A CO AUTHOR
THANK YOU. A. B. HONOR THINKING
THE STATE. ANYONE ELSE. HI
SEEING NONE YOU MAY CLOSE YES I
WANT TO THANK FIRST PHONE I
THINK THIS BECAUSE FOR HER
QUESTIONS LABOR AND I WANT TO
THINK THAT THE SPONSORS AND
SEALER FOR THE CONTINUED WORK
ON THIS AS WELL AS THE
COMMITTEE- AS MISS GONZALEZ
KNOWS BECAUSE WE HAD PROTRACTED
CONVERSATIONS AROUND THE VOTE
ON THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE THIS
IS A REALLY IMPORTANT PART OF
GETTING ME COMFORTABLE WITH THE
SMALL BUSINESSES AN ATTORNEY I
UNDERSTAND THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE ACCESS MALL
BUSINESS HAVE STAGE ARE INTO
ATTORNEYS. AND EVEN IF THEY
WANTED TO COMPLY THEY MAY
ACCIDENTLY NONCOMPLIANCE OF
GIVING THEM A PATHWAY TO GET
THE EMPLOYEE THIS RIGHTS AND
EMPLOYERS AS PROTECTION IS
REALLY IMPORTANT I THINK WE'RE
JUST MAKING THAT RIGHT MORE
MEANINGFUL FOR BOTH PARTIES AND
SO WE TOOK ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY THE
QUESTION THAT WAS POSED IN
LABOR AND I RESPECT THAT. AND I.
THANK YOU. WE DO HAVE A MOAT
AROUND LOOKING FOR A MOTION.
THANKS MOTION AND A SECOND
THANK YOU THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CALDERON PLEASE STONE AYE STONE
AYE GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER AYE
CHAU CHIU DAVIES DAVEY SECOND
SALAS DOLLARS AYE HOLDEN KALRA.
OVER AYE KILEY KELLY I
MAIENSCHEIN REYES. THE BILLS
OUT THANK YOU CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU MISTER BLOOM I WERE ITEM
NUMBER. TWO EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY
ONE. HI THERE. GOOD MORNING
THIS CHAIRMAN MEMBERS LET ME
BEGIN BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH MY
OFFICE ON AMENDMENTS WHICH I'LL
BE. ACCEPTING THIS MORNING
THANK YOU AB SEVEN TWENTY ONE
WILL MAKE INVALID ANY DENSITY
RESTRICTION AND PRIVATE
COVENANTS THAT DO NOT ALIGN
WITH CURRENT LOCAL ZONING.
PRIVATE COVENANTS OR AGREEMENTS
ATTACHED TO A PROPERTY AND
REMAIN ENFORCEABLE EVEN AFTER
THE PROPERTY IS SOLD. WHAT WE
ALL KNOW THAT UNTIL THE MID
TWENTIETH CENTURY RACIAL
RESTRICTIONS AND COVENANTS WERE
USED TO REDLINE AND SEGREGATE
NEIGHBORHOODS THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE HAS SINCE MADE
RACIALLY RESTRICTIVE COVENANTS
UNENFORCEABLE HOWEVER THESE
COVENANTS OFTEN CONTAIN OTHER
VESTIGES OF DISCRIMINATION SUCH
AS LIMITS. ON THE NUMBER AND
SIZE OF UNITS THAT CAN BE BUILT.
THE RESTRICTIONS IN THESE
COVENANTS ARE OFTENTIMES IN
CONFLICT WITH LOCAL ZONING THAT
WOULD OTHERWISE ALLOW FOR MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING DEVELOPMENT. AND
DESPITE THEIR DISCRIMINATORY
ORIGIN AND CLEAR CONFLICT WITH
LOCAL ZONING LAWS THESE
RESTRICTIONS REMAIN ENFORCEABLE
AGAINST AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPER WHICH BRINGS US TO
THIS BILL. THREATS OF LAWSUITS
OVER THESE COVENANTS MAKE IT
DIFFICULT IF NOT IMPOSSIBLE FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
TO GET TITLE INSURANCE COVERAGE
AND FUNDING FROM LENDERS. THE
TIME AND EXPENSE NEEDED TO
REMOVE THE COVENANTS DETERRED
DEVELOPERS FROM DEVELOPING ON
THESE OTHERWISE IDEAL PROJECT
SITES AND SO UNDER AB SEVEN
TWENTY ONE PRIVATE LANDOWNERS
WHO NO LONGER RESIDE ON THE
PROPERTY. CANNOT USE COVENANTS
TO CURTAIL MUCH NEEDED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
THIS MEASURE CLARIFIES THAT
DENSITY RESTRICTIONS AND
PRIVATE COVENANTS ARE
UNENFORCEABLE AGAINST A 1100%
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
AB SEVEN TWENTY ONE ALSO
PRESERVES AND STRENGTHENS LOCAL
CONTROL BY INVALIDATING
RESTRICTIONS THAT CONFLICT WITH
LOCAL ZONING. AB SEVEN TWENTY
ONE IS A MUCH NEEDED MEASURE TO
REMOVE UNNECESSARY BARRIERS IN
OUR EFFORTS IN TACKLING THE
HOUSING CRISIS I HAVE VOTE.
TESTIFYING ON THE BILL TODAY
TARA BEROSSUS WITH THE
COMMUNITY CORPORATION OF SANTA
MONICA AND BRANDON YEAH WITH
PUBLIC COUNCIL THANK YOU I DO
HAVE THOSE TWO WITNESSES
INDICATED HERE BOTH WITH US ON
THE TELEPHONE. TEREBRA ASK US
ARE YOU WITH US. MORNING
HONORABLE KAREN MEMBERS MINING
HARDWARE OUT THIS AND THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF COMMUNITY
CORPORATE SANTA MONICA BERMAN
THANK NONPROFIT THAT IS
OPERATED AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
THE AFFLUENT WEST SIDE OF LA
COUNTY FOR ALMOST FORTY YEARS.
I'D LIKE TO START BY THINKING
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RICHARD BLOOM
FOR CHAMPIONING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR MANY YEARS WE ARE
HERE TODAY THE CO SPONSOR OF
EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE BECAUSE
OF THE PORTABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS WE BELIEVE IT'S
IMPORTANT TO SHARE WITH POLICY
MAKERS THE OBSTACLES WE FACE IN
THE HOPES THEY CAN BE FIXED.
THE ISSUES RAISED BY EIGHTY
SEVEN TWENTY ONE ARE
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
THEY PERPETUATE HISTORICAL
SEGREGATION OF NEIGHBORHOODS
ASKING FOR ABOUT HOUSING
DEVELOPER ACTING RESTRICTIVE
COVENANTS WITH ITS EXTREMELY
UPSETTING RACIAL PROVISIONS
ALONG WITH ACCOMPANYING DENSITY
RESTRICTIONS MULTIPLE TIMES
USUALLY HAVE CHOSEN TO WALK
AWAY FROM THOSE PROJECTS BUT
AFTER THE EVENTS OF THE PAST
YEAR I FEEL IT'S IMPORTANT
CHALLENGES STATUS QUO AND TAKE
AWAY THE POWER THAT THE
SEGREGATIONIST COVENANTS THE
PAD. TO REMOVE SUCH PRESIDENT
CAN COST A LOT OF MONEY AND
THEN EXTENDED COURT PROCESS AND
FOR PROPERTIES ALREADY THE
OWNER DESIGNATED FOR MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING WE SHOULDN'T
HAVE TO GO THROUGH THAT IN ONE
PROJECT WE'RE WORKING ON
CURRENTLY THE PROPERTIES
DESIGNATED MULTI FAMILY BY THE
CITY AND THE ONLY THING
STANDING IN THE WAY IS THIS
PRIVATE OUTDATED COVENANT
AMONGST OWNERS FROM THE
NINETEEN FORTIES. WHICH
PROHIBITS MULTI FAMILY
DEVELOPMENTS IT WOULD PROVIDE
OVER A HUNDRED UNITS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN A
COMMUNITY THAT HAS NO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING YOU TOO MANY
RESTRICTIVE COVENANTS RECORDED
IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD. WE DEEPLY
APPRECIATE ARE COSPONSORED
PUBLIC COUNCIL WHO EXPLAIN MORE
ABOUT THE COVENANTS AND IT'S
WORKED VERY HARD TO HELP US
THROUGH THE PROCESS THAT MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CAN BE BUILT
WE CAN'T BEGIN TO ADDRESS
EXCLUSIONARY NEIGHBORHOODS
WITHOUT ADDRESSING RESTRICTIVE
COVENANTS WE URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
SEGREGATIONIST. PRACTICES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND THEN BRENT
PATH. THE BOSTON MEMBERS MY
NAME PLANET HEY I'M STAFF OF
TEN WITH PUBLIC COUNCIL THE
NATION LARGEST BONO FIRM MY
WORK FOCUSES ON A HOUSE
INCREASE DEVELOPMENT I WANT TO
FIRST THANK THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE CAREFUL
ATTENTION TO THE HOUSING CRISIS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. THE
QUESTION OF WHERE DENSE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CAN AND
SHOULD BE BUILT ITS SOMETIMES
CONTROVERSIAL BUT THE DECISION
SHOULD BE MADE BY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS IN COMPLIANCE
WITH STATE LAW AND INDIVIDUAL
PROPERTY OWNERS NOT OPENLY
RACIST DEVELOPERS FROM THE
NINETEEN TWENTIES AND THIRTIES.
MANY PEOPLE ARE. WITH THE
HISTORY OF RACIALLY RESTRICTIVE
COVENANTS THAT WERE DESIGNED TO
PROHIBIT PEOPLE OF COLOR FROM
LIVING AN ENTIRE NEIGHBORHOODS.
UNFORTUNATELY THE LEGACY OF
THOSE RACES RESTRICTION
CALLICOTT. RECORDED
RESTRICTIONS THAT LIMIT
DEVELOPMENT ON A GIVEN PARKS UP
TO A CERTAIN NUMBER OF
RESIDENTIAL UNITS OR TO A
CERTAIN NUMBER OF BUILDINGS.
ARE OFTEN TREATED AS
ENFORCEABLE TODAY. EVEN IF
THOSE RESTRICTIONS ARE MORE
LIMITING THAN THE APPLICABLES
RUNNING CODE. BY LAND USE RULES
AND EVEN THOSE RESTRICTIONS ARE
CONTAINED IN THE SAME DOCUMENT.
THAT EXPLICITLY RACIST
RESTRICTIONS ON WHO MAY LIVE
THERE. EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE
WOULD MAKE THE PRIVATE AND THE
RESTRICTIONS IN RECORDED
COVENANTS UNENFORCEABLE AGAINST
1100% AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT. YEAH BY REMOVING A
SIGNIFICANT BARRIER TO THE
CONSTRUCTION OF A HOUSING FOR
LOW INCOME PEOPLE. IN
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT HIS HAVE
HISTORICALLY EXCLUDED THEM.
JUST LIKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MODIFY EXPLICITLY BASIS
RESTRICTION. EIGHTY SEVEN
TWENTY ONE IT'S NOT THE NEAR
IDENTICAL PROCESS OF MODIFYING.
ITS PRIVATE DENSITY DESTRUCTION.
IMPORTANTLY THE BILL WOULDN'T
MAKE ME WOULD EVER. ANY CHANGE
TO LOCAL CODE BY MAN USE RULES.
IT WOULD SIMPLY ALLOW PROPERTY
OWNERS TO BUILD MUCH AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ON A GIVEN PROPERTY AT
THE APPLICABLES ONLY CODE WOULD
ALLOW. ADDITIONALLY THE BILL
DOES NOT DO AWAY WITH
RESTRICTIVE COVENANT ENTIRELY.
ANY RESTRICTIONS ON THE USE OF
PROPERTY NOT RELATED TO THE
SITE LOCATION OR NUMBER OF
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT THAT CAN
BE BUILT THERE WOULD REMAIN
FULLY ENFORCEABLE. AND EIGHTY
SEVEN TWENTY ONE EXPLICITLY
ALLOWS THE LOCAL COMMUNITY TO
RETAIN ITS CHARACTER BY
ENFORCING DESIGNED AND
AESTHETICALLY STRINGENT OR BY
INPUTTING MAINTENANCE FEES TO
KEEP COMMON AREAS IN GOOD
REPAIR. ON BEHALF OF PUBLIC
COUNCIL IN THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING COMMUNITY WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR VOTE
ON EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE. TO
CONTINUE THE PROCESS OF
RECTIFYING THE HARM OF
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY OF
RESIDENTIAL SEGREGATION. AND
DISCRIMINATORY. HOUSING
POLICIES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
RIGHT IS THERE ANYONE. HERE THE
CHAMBERS WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN
TWENTY ONE. ALL RIGHT SAY NONE
ABOUT THE REMOTE TESTIMONY SITE.
SEEING NONE WITNESS VIDEO ROOM.
SEEING NONE RIGHT OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OF THE LINES PLEASE
FOR THOSE WHO'D LIKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR A BI SEVEN
TWENTY ONE WE'RE TAKING NAME
AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT. IF YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB SEVEN TWO ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND I CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT
TENANTS YOU IT'LL JUST BE ONE
MOMENT FOR THE FIRST COMMENT
THANK YOU. FORTY NINE THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADISON DO COSTS WITH
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
SHARON MEMBERS THIS IS ON THE
RISE FROM ALSO ON BEHALF OF
PUBLIC ADVOCATES WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN
TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RISE FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS JACKSON LOOP
WITH THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF NONPROFIT
HOUSING IN STRONG SUPPORTER OF.
EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE. THANK
YOU I FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS JACKIE AB
WITH HOUSING CALIFORNIA AND
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I'M THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
LESLIE LAMBERT WITH SANTA
MONICA FORWARD IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN TWENTY ONE.
THANK YOU RIGHT FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ROBBIE JONES BATTLE MONICA
ATTY- COMMITTEE FOR RACIAL
JUSTICE AND BLACK SANTA MONICA
BLACK AGENDA STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB. SEVEN TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU
RIGHT FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE FOUR SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE MORNING JOCULAR GATES
WITHIN APART COMMUNITY PARTNERS
ARE STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
LINE SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THE SAKE
HAHNEMANN WITH PUBLIC COUNCIL
IN LOS ANGELES AND JOHN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU RIGHT WE WILL THEN
MOVE TO. OPPOSITION AND I HAVE
TO OPPOSITION WITNESSES MARK
FENSTER MAKER CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF LAND TRUSTS AND
ANTHONY HELTON CALIFORNIA LAND
TITLE ASSOCIATION. BOTH WITH US
ON THE PHONE MISTER FENSTER
MAKER ARE YOU HERE. I AM THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND YOU KNOW
THE NEW WANTS TO
INTERPRETATION- WE HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL AGAIN
MARCH INSTAGRAM HAPPEN THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL LAND TRUST
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PROTECT THOSE CONCERNS TO BE
SEVEN TWENTY ONE. I THANK YOU
TO THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR YOUR WORK ON THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS VETERAN
ALICE'S SON OUR CONCERNS.
REGARDING THE THREAT THAT
EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE POSES
TO CONSERVATION EASEMENTS. BACK
CALIFORNIA FIRST ESTABLISH THE
LEGAL FRAMEWORK FOR
CONSERVATION EASEMENT IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE.
CALIFORNIA HAS SINCE RELIED.
UPON IT IS GOING TO CONSERVE
THE ENVIRONMENT. WHEN PROTECTED
BY. EASEMENTS TIRING READ.
DISAPPEARING SACRED COMMENDED
BE. AND REVERSING BECAUSE I
HABITAT NEEDED FOR ENDANGERED
SPECIES THREATENED BY CLIMATE
CHANGE. CONSERVATION AND
CONSERVATION EASEMENTS HAVE
BEEN AND WILL CONTINUE TO BE A
VITAL TOOL MEETING MANY OF THE
STATE'S ENVIRONMENTAL CLIMATE
CHANGE AND BIODIVERSITY
RESTORATION GOALS. HE KILLED
HIS MEMBER LAND TRUSTS OTHER
NONPROFITS PURCHASE
CONSERVATION EASEMENT. INSURED
WILL CONTRIBUTIONS OR CHOIR IN
PUBLIC FUNDING FOR LOCAL STATE
AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS FOR
COMBINATION THERAPY. YOU KNOW
IN THE PUBLIC DOLLARS TO THE
SECURING THE CONSERVATION LAND.
I RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
THESE LANDS PUBLIC MONEY ALSO
FUND CONSERVATION EASEMENTS
YOUR FEDERAL TAX DEDUCTION
SPECTATE TAX CREDIT. THOSE
FEDERAL TAX DEDUCTION LIMIT
IRAQI INTERPRETATION OF THIS
BILL WILL CONTINUE TO CAUSE US
CONCERN. WE ARE CONCERNED THAT
THE IRAQIS INTERPRETATION WILL
LEAD THEM TO DECLARE THAT THE
BILL NULLIFIES PUT AT THE
PETROL NATURE CONSERVATION IS
NOT THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT CONSERVATION EASEMENT TO
BE VALID MUST BE IN PERPETUITY.
AND THAT THE IRS IS MADE THEN
SHE TO REMOVE THE LANDOWNERS
TAX DEDUCTION AND POTENTIALLY
IN LINE THE ENTIRE EASEMENT. IN
ADDITION WE ARE DEEPLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE CHILLING
EFFECT THAT THIS MAY HAVE ON
LANDOWNERS. AND WILLINGNESS TO
ENTER INTO CONSERVATION
EASEMENT. MANY OF OUR MEMBER
LAND TRUSTS ASK THAT LANDOWNERS
DONATE A PORTION OF THE
EASEMENT. TO BRING DOWN THE
PURCHASE PRICE AND THEN YOUR
THREAT OF A TAX DEDUCTION NOT
BEEN MAINTAINED IS ENOUGH TO
DETER MANY LANDOWNERS. THAT
SAID WE'RE REALLY ENCOURAGED BY
THE CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD
WITH THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE AND
THE SPONSORS TO DATE. I MEAN
MANAGE PROPOSED HERE TODAY BY
THE COMMITTEE. AND WE ARE
ENCOURAGED BY THE RIGHTEOUS
OUTCOME FISTBALL HOPE TO
ACHIEVE IN TERMS OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CALIFORNIA. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING OUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICES CAN SPONSOR. AND
RESOLVING OUR ISSUES BUT FOR
TODAY WE STILL HAVE CONCERNS
WITH THE BILL. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU THEY WILL GO TO
ANTHONY HELTON. THANK YOU
MISTER TRIMMERS ANTHONY HELTON
WITH THE LTA I WE HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
STAFF AND SPONSOR FOR WORKING
WITH US TO TRY AND RESOLVE OUR
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL- AND
ALSO APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. WHICH WE THINK
IMPROVE THE WORKABILITY- ISSUES
OF THE BILL. ALSO WANT TO THANK
GOD COMMITTEE STAFFERS WORK ON
THE BILL WE THINK THE- MAIN
ALICE'S. IS WELL WRITTEN AND
DOES A GOOD JOB OF SUMMARIZING.
THE OUTSTANDING ISSUES. I WOULD
LIKE TO NOTE THAT SEAL TA IS
NOT OPPOSED TO THE- OUR GOAL OF
THE BILL- WE SUPPORT- THE GOAL
OF DEVELOPING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING- WITH THAT SAID WE
THINK THE- BILLS PERMISSIVE-
NATURE TOWARDS THE- RECORDING
OF THE RESTRICTIVE COVENANT
MODIFICATIONS FORMS AS-
PROBLEMATIC- WE THINK IT WILL.
INCREASE THE LIKELIHOOD OF
LITIGATION AND- INHIBIT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE- TYPES OF
PROJECTS THAT THE BILL- SEEKING
TO PROMOTE- WE- WE'RE
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING- SIMPLE
AMENDMENT- TO REQUIRE THE
RECORDING OF THE- MODIFICATION
FOR- WE THINK- IT'LL REMOVE
AMBIGUITY FROM REAL PROPERTY
RECORDS- REDUCE LIKELIHOOD OF
LITIGATION AND- BETTER ENABLE
TITLE COMPANY PARTICIPATION ON
THESE PROJECTS. WE DO NOT THINK
THIS IS AN ONEROUSREQUIREMENTS- RECORDING FORMS
IS SIMPLE IT'S INEXPENSIVE.
SOMETHING THAT DEVELOPERS
ALREADY HAVE TO DO DURING THE
COURSE OF DEVELOPING GIVEN
PROJECT- WE THINK IT'S A WORTHY
STEP TO TAKE GIVEN THE BENEFIT
THAT WE THINK IT CONFERS- SO WE
HOPE TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE OUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE-
AUTHORS- OFFICE AND THE SPONSOR
AND- WHAT WE HOPE TO BE ABLE TO
RESOLVE THOSE CONCERNS AND
REMOVE OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
ACCORDINGLY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. IS THERE ANYONE IN THE-
HEARING ROOM WHO'D LIKE TO
INDICATE OPPOSITION TO AB SEVEN
TWENTY ONE. C. NINE HOW ABOUT
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY SITE.
SEEING NONE WITNESS VIDEO ROOM.
SEEING NONE RIGHT OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
ANYONE WHO'D LIKE TO INDICATE
OPPOSITION TO AB. SEVEN TWENTY
ONE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB SEVEN
TWO ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. LEVINE
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI I BELIEVE I'M ONE THIRTY
EIGHT. I WOULD LIKE TO. I'M
PATRICIA HOFFMAN I- AM
REPRESENTING SANTA MONICA'S FOR
RENTER'S RIGHTS AND THE SANTA
MONICA DEMOCRATIC CLUB AND I
SPEAK STRONGLY IN FAVOR OF-
SEVEN TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU.
YOU'RE RIGHT SEVENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS RAY
LOW BROUGH CATALYST WE OPPOSED
AB SEVEN TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
I THANK YOU FOR YOU MAY CLOSE
ALLIANCE WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND. THIS
WILL BE MY CLOSE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BURSTS- WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH-
OPPOSITION- THAT YOU FOR TODAY
FROM THE LAND TRUSTS AND-
COUNTY RECORDER'S I THINK WE'VE
MADE A LOT OF. PROGRESS THAT
ARE EMBEDDED IN THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WE TAKE TODAY BUT WE WILL
CONTINUE THOSE CONVERSATIONS
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. PHONE. THANK YOU YOU HAVE A
MOTION AND SECOND THAT MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALDERON PLEASE
STONE HI STONE AYE GALLAGHER.
YEAH GALLAGHER NO CHAO. TO
DAVIES DAVIES NO GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN ALL RIGHT
KALRA AYE KILEY. KILEY NO
MAIENSCHEIN REYES RAYSIDE THE
BILL NEEDS TO MORE SO FOR THAT
ON CALL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THIS COOPER. OUR ITEMNUMBER
FOUR AB. THREE EIGHTY SIX.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS
WITH THE UNCERTAINTY IN THE
FINANCIAL MARKETS OUR PENSION
SYSTEMS ARE WORKING TO DO OUR
PART TO PROTECT THE PENSIONS OF
ALL OF OUR PUBLIC SERVANTS AB
THREE EIGHTY SIX INTO TO GIVE
OUR PUBLIC PENSIONS THE ABILITY
TO ACCESS EVERY TOOL POSSIBLE
TO INVEST AND MANAGE
CALIFORNIANS PENSION FUNDS.
THIS BILL CREATES A PUBLIC
RECORDS DISCLOSURE STRUCTURE
FELL OUT PUBLIC PENSION SYSTEMS
LIKE CALPERS TO AGGRESSIVELY
PURSUE INVESTMENTS IN THE
PRIVATE LOAN MARKET. THE SAME
WAY YOUR FINANCIAL INFORMATION
IS HELD CONFIDENTIAL BY YOUR
MORTGAGE COMPANY THIS BILL SAYS
A PAY STRUCTURE TO PROTECT IT
BORROWS INFORMATION IF IT
PENSION SYSTEM LIVES CAPITAL
THROUGH A PRIVATE LOAN
AGREEMENT. THE BILL STRIKES THE
RIGHT BALANCE BETWEEN THE
CONFIDENTIALITY NECESSARY FOR
BORROWERS IN THE TRANSPARENCY
REQUIRED THE PUBLIC PENSION
SYSTEM WITH ME IS DANA BROWN
CALPERS LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS
DIVISION CHIEF. WHO IS A
SPONSOR OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
MISS COOPER THERE ARE
AMENDMENTS LISTED IN THE BILL
YOU'RE TAKING THOSE AUTHORS OF
A MONTH. YES SIR. THANK YOU.
CORRECT WE'RE HAVE ALSO DANNY
BROWN FROM CALPERS IS WITH US
ON THE TELEPHONE. GO AHEAD
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON DANNY BROWN AND
HAPPEN TO CALPERS BOARD OF
ADMINISTRATION SPONSORS THE
BILL LET ME START BY THINKING
WE OPTED FOR HIS CONTINUED
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND
THE WORK BY THE COMMITTEE AND
THE REPUBLICAN CAUCUS STAFF-
PRIVATE DEBT TRANSACTIONS ARE
INVESTMENTS BY THE PENSION FUND
SERVING AS A LENDER TO A PUBLIC
OR PRIVATE COMPANIES SEEKING
CAPITAL FOR SUCH THINGS AS
OPERATIONS ARE GROW. CURRENTLY
THE FUND MAKES INVESTMENTS BY
PAIN OUTSIDE FUND MANAGERS TO
MANAGE THE TRANSACTIONS. EIGHTY
THREE EIGHTY SIX CREATES A
DISCLOSURE STRUCTURE FOR
BRINGING THE MANAGEMENT OF
PRIVATE DEBT INVESTMENTS AND
HOUSE. WHICH WOULD PROVIDE THE
CALPERS BOARD INVESTMENT STAFF
MORE DIRECT CONTROLLED
INVESTMENTS INVOICE MANAGEMENT
FEES PAID TO EXTERNAL
INVESTMENT MANAGERS. THIS
DISCLOSURE STRUCTURES
CONSISTENT WITH CURRENT LAW
RELATED TO PUBLIC RECORDS
DISCLOSURE FOR EXTREMELY MANAGE
PRIVATE INVESTMENTS FROM THE
PENSION FUND AND RECENT
DISCLOSURE RULES THE
LEGISLATURE ESTABLISHED IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN PROPOSAL
THANKS THAT ARE CREATED BY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. MODELING
THREE D. STE AB THREE SIX AFTER
CURRENT LAW IS IMPORTANT TO BE
CONSISTENT WITH OUR WORST AND
MARKET EXPECTATIONS IN ORDER
FOR CALPERS INVESTMENT STAFF TO
COMPETITIVELY INTRODUCED MARKET
AT A SCALE THAT MAKES SENSE FOR
THE PENSION FUND. CALPERS
TECHNOLOGIST LEGITIMATE
INTEREST OF THE PUBLIC IN
KNOWING HOW PUBLIC MONIES ARE
INVESTED AS WELL AS THE
OBLIGATION TO BE RESPONSIVE TO
INFORMATION REQUEST. WE BELIEVE
THE PROPOSED DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS BALANCES EXISTING
MARKET EXPECTATIONS WITH THE
NEED FOR TRANSPARENCY AND
CALPERS INVESTMENT ACTIVITIES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. SO IS THERE
ANYONE HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE SIX. SEEING
NONE ANYONE OF THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY SITE. SEEING NONE
ABOUT THE WITNESS VIDEO ROOM.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR THOSE WOULD
LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR A
BI. THREE EIGHTY SIX. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE EIGHT SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WHAT'S ONE THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING DAILY
GIVENS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME RIGHT WE WILL THEN
MOVE TO OPPOSITION I HAVE TO
OPPOSITION WITNESSES LISTED. OF
THE FREEDOM PARTY OF CALIFORNIA
AND DAVID SOARES OF THE RETIRED
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES CALIFORNIA.
CITY WEBER ARE YOU WITH US. ALL
RIGHT DAVID SORCERY WITH US. GO
AHEAD PLEASE GOOD MORNING
HUNDREDS STORIES I'VE LIVED IN
SANTA CRUZ FOR THE FORTY FIVE
YEARS AND I'M CALPERS
BENEFICIARY RETIRED AFTER
SERVING THIRTY TWO YEARS AS A
PROSECUTOR IN SILICON VALLEY
I'M HERE REPRESENTING THE
RETIRED PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
CALPERS LITTLE TRUCK ASSETS YOU
COME PUMP PUMP JACK. BUT COULD
REFUSE TO AND HELP PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT THE PHONE JACK WAS
OWNED BY GOVERNOR. AS WELL AS
THE TERM IMPOSSIBLE FOR THAT
MONTH WELL I DON'T THINK BERMAN
AGO WHO WOULD ENTER THE A TRY.
THIS IS EXACTLY THE SORT OF
THING THAT EIGHTY EIGHTY SIX OF
A LAUGH UNLIKE CURRENTLY
EXAMPLE TURNED INTO THINKING.
WHICH ARE REGULATED BY THE
ACTION SCENES HE'S LONG WOULD
NOT BE SUBJECT TO FEDERAL
OVERSIGHT. THE STAFF ANALYSIS
PREPARED FOR TODAY'S HEARING
COLLECTION STATE THIS BILL HAD
TO BE WITHDRAWN IN THE LAST
SESSION WE CALPERS CHIEF
INVESTMENT OFFICER THEN THEN
SUDDENLY DESIGN. I'D LIKE TO
FOCUS THE COMMITTEES
UNDERSTANDING ON WHAT IS THE
MOST. GOVERNMENTS YOU CAN BE
SURE INCLUDING LATE BEHIND
MAINE'S RESIGNATION. PRIVATE
EQUITY OF NASA PLASTICS FROM
YOUR SIX POINT 7% OF HELPERS
HOLDING HOW THE DECLINING
RETURN PROFILE JETTA PROJECTED
TO CONTINUE. DOLLARS IN
MANAGEMENT AND PERFORMANCE. THE
MR MAIN DISCLOSED OF HIS
CONTACT OF INTEREST. ENGINE
FORM SEVEN HUNDRED AND HIGHER
THAN NINETY YEAH IN TWENTY ONE
BUT NAY WAS ALLOWED TO DIRECT
BILL AND BUT INVEST TO BUY
WHICH CONTINUE TO HOLD FOR THE-
PERSONAL INTEREST. WELL THAN
REQUIRED OF US WE'VE BEEN
REQUIRE BY THE SHE WILL HAVE TO
YEARS CALPERS YOU KNOW MARSHALL
CROSSED BOARD PRESS HENRY JONES
UNDER SMALL BUT THE MAJORITY OF
THE WHOLE HERE HE HE HE AND
APOSS. WELCOME JONES ADMITTED
TO BLOOMBERG THAT THEY CHOSE
ALL TWENTY PEOPLE COMMITTEE
CHAIRED FROST ON THE EXCEPT TO
MAKE A SOUND IF THE BAD MEDAL
INFLICTING BASSMAN. TO SOME
CRAZY WITH THAT THE JUDGE KERR
AND NOT THE OFFICIAL. UNDER THE
FORM SINCE IT'S SINCE. WE WILL
CONTINUE TO MAIL A FULL AND BUT
BECAUSE HENRY JOHNSON THEM OUT
OF THE QUOTES. ON AUGUST AND
HAS THE WITH A- SHE COMES
SURPRISE TO IN EIGHTEEN WITHIN
JOHN JOHN ALTERNATIVE THE OF
WHAT IN PUBLIC WORKERS THAT'S
ALONG BROUGHT WHICH PURSUING A
MASTER'S DEGREE SHE IS OUT
SCHOOL WOULD YOU FORMER CLERK
TYPIST WE'VE NEVER BEEN.
ADMITTED BECAUSE AND WE DON'T
SIMPLY.
CALPERS JUST. CRIED
INVESTOR REPORT HELLO IS READY
THIS. MARTIN CANCER IN. IN DEBT
THERE ARE CHILDREN INVEST PART.
HELLO NEED TO RAISE TRANSFER.
NOT ALLOWED I RESPECT ASK TO BE
ON NUMBERS PROTECT OUR COUNTY
BY THE TO SEND FUNDS. AND BILL
GROSS FOR THANK. COMMITTEE GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS SIKI WEBER
AND THE LEGISLATIVE LIAISON FOR
PEACE FREEDOM. OF CAL. I'D LIKE
TO START BY SAYING THAT THERE'S
A BIG. BETWEEN SAID MONEY TO
PRIVATE SECTOR MONEY. THE
PRIVATE SECTOR WORKS FOR THE P.
EACH AND IT SAYS IT MUST BE
SAID TO A- LEVEL OF OVERSIGHT.
AND FOR MOST PRIVATE SECTOR
BUSINESS ACTIVITIES ARE NOT NOT
ENOUGH. AB THREE EIGHT SIX IS
NOW A VALID CAL THREE TO AND IN
AND MANAGED PRIVATE FUNDS ALSO
KNOWN AS PRIVATE. BECAUSE THEY
ARE ALREADY A MAY INVESTOR IN
PRIVATE DEBT FUNDS. AND THE
RETURNS NOT THAT GREAT. THIS
BILL IS NOT IS THIS BILL IS
ABOUT FOR. PRIVACY TO CONCEAL
THE D. OF LONG. IT WOULD ALLOW
LOANS TO SHALL COME. THE IN THE
REAL BORROWER. IT WOULD. READ
IT WOULD TREAT UNSAFE LOAN THE
SAME SECURE LOAN WHICH WOULD IN
THE LEVEL. IT WOULD THE POWER
FROM KNOWING. WHETHER THEY IS
ANY WAY. THE NUMBER. AND OTHER
TERMS OF THE LOAN. OUR
OPPOSITION TO A. B. THREE EIGHT
SIX PLACE CONCERNS. THAT IT
COULD PROVIDE A COVER ON FIRST
CRAP. YOU THANK YOU. OR IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WHO'D LIKE TO INDICATE
OPPOSITION DAVEY THREE SIX.
SEEING REMOTE TEST SAY. C. NONE
WITNESSES ROOM. SEEING NONE
RIGHT OPERATOR WOULD YOU THE
LINE PLEASE FOR WHO WOULD LIKE
TO THE DATA TO AB D. SO. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
ENACTED. TO AB THREE EIGHT SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
NO COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU OPERATOR YOU
MAY CLOSE ALLIANCE WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. RIGHT
SIGNAL DISCOVERY MAY CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU I'M LOOKING FOR MOTION THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. ALL RIGHT MISS
COOPER SING THE MOTION WILL
TAKE THIS UP. WE GET MORE
MEMBERS HERE OKAY THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVE TO ITEM
NUMBER FIVE MR GABRIEL SB. FIVE
EIGHTY SEVEN. NOT AT THIS TIME.
GO AHEAD THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS IN RECENT YEARS
CALIFORNIANS ACROSS THE
POLITICAL SPECTRUM HAVE BECOME
INCREASINGLY ALARMED ABOUT THE
ROLE OF SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES
AND MODERATING OUR PUBLIC
DISCOURSE FOR MANY PARTICULARLY
FOLLOWING THE HORRIFIC ASSAULT
ON OUR DEMOCRACY AT THE US
CAPITOL EARLIER THIS YEAR THESE
CONCERNS CENTER AROUND THE ROLE
THAT SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS
PLAY IN PROMOTING HATE SPEECH
DISINFORMATION CONSPIRACY
THEORIES. AND VIOLENT EXTREMISM.
FOR OTHERS IT IS THE MYSTERY
BEHIND WHY CERTAIN INDIVIDUALS
IN CONTENT AND NOT OTHERS ARE
SUBJECT TO DISCIPLINARY ACTION.
ON BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE
THERE IS GROWING CONCERN ABOUT
SEVEREPOLITICAL POLARIZATION
AND THE ABILITY OF A HANDFUL OF
COMPANIES TO PROFOUNDLY SHAPE
THE PUBLIC DISCOURSE THAT IS
CENTRAL TO OUR DEMOCRACY. AB
FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN ADDRESSES
THESE CONCERNS BY REQUIRING
SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES TO SHARE
BASIC INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR
CONTENT MODERATION PRACTICES
WITH CONSUMERS. IN PARTICULAR
THE BILL WOULD REQUIRE THE
LARGEST AND MOST SOPHISTICATED
PLATFORMS TO DISCLOSE. THEIR
CONTENT MODERATION POLICIES.
HOW THOSE POLICIES ARE ENFORCED
AND KEY METRICS AND DATA AROUND
THE ENFORCEMENT OF THOSE
POLICIES. TO BE CLEAR THIS BILL
DOES NOT REQUIRE THESE
COMPANIES TO HAVE ANY SPECIFIC
POLICIES. NOR DOES IT REQUIRE
THEM TO UNDERTAKE ANY TYPE OF
ENFORCEMENT. IT SIMPLY REQUIRES
THEM TO BE OPEN AND TRANSPARENT
WITH POLICYMAKERS AND THE
PUBLIC ABOUT WHAT. IF ANYTHING
THEY'RE DOING TO MODERATE
SPEECH ON THEIR PLATFORMS. THIS
NARROW PRESSURE SPECS THE FIRST
AMENDMENT FEDERAL PREEMPTION
WELL AT THE SAME TIME PROVIDING
MEANINGFUL TRANSPARENCY AND
MUCH NEEDED PUBLIC
ACCOUNTABILITY. IN SHORT THIS
BILL WOULD REQUIRE SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS TO COME CLEAN ABOUT
HOW THEY ARE MODERATING
CONTENT. SO THAT WE CAN ALL
BETTER UNDERSTAND HOW THEY ARE
AMPLIFYING CERTAIN VOICES AND
SILENCING OTHERS. THE PUBLIC
AND POLICY MAKERS DESERVE NO
LESS. FINALLY I'D LIKE TO KNOW
THAT WE APPRECIATE SEVERAL THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION'S. THE AMENDMENT WE
ARE TAKING TODAY ADDRESS SOME
OF THOSE CONCERNS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THEM TO
STRENGTHEN THE BILL. IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME I'D LIKE TO
MOVE TO MY WITNESS LEARN CRAP
FROM THE ANTI DEFAMATION
LEAGUE. I LOOK FORWARD TO
ANSWERING ANY QUESTIONS AND
AGAIN WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE STAFFER
THEIR SYSTEMS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TAKING THE AMENDMENTS AS
AUTHORS OF ELEMENTS THAT ARE
CORRECTED THANK YOU VERY GOOD.
RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION. AND A
SECOND AND WILL MOVE TO. LARA
CROFT FOR THE ANTI DEFAMATION
LEAGUE WHO'S WITH US ON THE
TELEPHONE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
AFTERNOON THANK YOU TO THE
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M
LAURIN CROP. COUNCIL FOR
TECHNOLOGY POLICY AND ADVOCACY
AT THE ANTI DEFAMATION LEAGUE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN. SINCE
NINETEEN THIRTEEN ADL'S MISSION
HAS BEEN TO STOP THE DEFAMATION
OF THE JEWISH PEOPLE AND
CONFIGURED JUSTICE AND FAIR
TREATMENT FOR ALL DEDICATED TO
COMBATING ANTISEMITISM
PREJUDICE AND BIGOTRY OF ALL
KINDS. AS WELL AS DEFENDING
DEMOCRATIC IDEALS AND PROMOTING
CIVIL RIGHTS. ADL IS A LEADING
VOICE IN FIGHTING HATE IN ALL
FORMS. INCLUDING ONLINE. YOU'RE
COMING OUT OF ONE OF THEM.
DIVISIVE ALLOW IN OUR TO.
AGAINST THE BACKDROP OF COPING
NINETEEN AND HORRIFYING OF
GEORGE BOY BRIANNA TAYLOR AND
RESEARCH TO TRY KILLINGS DANTE.
I'M TO LIDO AND MAKE BRIAN. NO
WAY NEW ANCHOR EVENTS WERE.
ONLINE NOT. AND IT CAN AROUND
SOCIAL ME ROLE IN. ANY
PROMOTING HATE RACISM. CROSSMAN
A IT DID FOR ME IS WHY FOUNDED.
FALSE ALLEGATIONS VOTER FOR
SPREAD ONLINE LET'S TAKE
VIOLENCE IN. THAT OUR NATION
CAPITAL THE MOST PREDICT.
TERRORIST IN HISTORY WHAT DO.
PLAY INCOME. OUT IN THE OPEN
UNTIL MEDIA. ONLINE HER IS ALSO
RAMPANT ACCORDING TO ADL'S WE
DATA 41% OF. HAVE A- ONLINE
ACROSS. AND ONE OF THREE OF
THOSE. A AT LEAST SOME HER. TO
A PROTECTED. AND THIS ISN'T
ONLY TAKING PLACE ON FRENCH MY
BOARD. 75% OF THOSE HARASSED
SUBTLETIES SOME. HAPPEN ON
FACEBOOK 24% ON TWITTER 21% ON
YOUTH. 15% ON. WELL RESOURCE
HIGHLY PROFITABLE PLUS TO TRY
LEARN CONCERN. EFFORTS SOCIAL
COMPANY TOMATO CON HI BEEN AND
I. AND BEST BUT ALSO TAKE
ARBITRARY BIASED AND ENACT.
MOST MAJOR PUBLISHED TRANSIT
EUROPE. BUT IN REALITY LIMIT
AND FOR. THE REPORT LAXITY AND
MEASURE NEEDED TO OUT OF UNDER.
HOW CAN ARE OR ARE NOT
PROTECTED. J. NEARLY AND TO
KNOW THE POST AND NATURE OF
EXTREME AND HE ONLINE. THE LACK
OF TRENDS OR ME AND FOR. APART
FROM ISN'T URGENT PROBLEM.
EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN WOULD
ADDRESS IT BY REQUIRING SO
MEDIA PER. TO PA TO THEIR
GUIDELINES AND WE'RE AROUND THE
END FOR. OF THEIR POLICIES WE
URGE YOU TO THE PLEDGES. THANK.
THANK YOU. THAT IS THE ONLY
WITNESS HAVE LIST IS THERE HERE
IN THE HERE ROOM WHO LIKE TO
SUPPORT FOR A BI FIVE A SEVEN.
SEEING NONE OF THE REMOTE TEST
SITE. SEEING NONE WHAT THIS
VIDEO. SEEING NONE ARE OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES THOSE
WHO TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR A
FIVE EIGHTIES. Q. IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
EIGHT SEVEN PLEASE PER ONE AND
THEN SEE AT THE TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ONE IN Q. IT'LL
JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR THAT
LINE THANK YOU.
AND OVER TO MY
NUMBER SEVENTY SEVEN. FIVE
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES MY NAME IS BOB HOPE MEN I'M
WITH ANTI DEFAMATION LEAGUE WE
SUPPORT EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY FIVE
AND MAY LETTER WHICH AND OF
OTHER. INCLUDE ACCOUNT TACK
ARMENIAN ASSEMBLY THE- IS
AMERICANS AND AS BRAND EMIGRATE
RIGHTS PROJECT JAPANESE
AMERICANS THAT IS LEAGUE-
BERKELEY CHOPPED CREE AMERICAN
LOS ANGELES LEAGUE OF UNITED
LATIN SAID NAILING IT FOR.
NATIONAL HISPANIC MEDIA
COALITION ORANGE COUNTY RACIAL
JUSTICE COLLABORATIVE WHEN BUSY
NOW ARMENIAN NATIONAL COMMITTEE
WESTERN REGION AND THAT THE CUT
INSTITUTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I NO FURTHER COMMENTS
YOU AT THE TIME I THINK YOU
WILL THEN MOVE TO OPPOSITION I
HAVE TO I WINS IS THE DILLON HI
OF THE IS. AND CHOI MOHAMMED OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE BOTH WITH US ON THE
TELEPHONE. WHAT HAPPENED ARE
YOU ARE YOU ON THE LINE. M.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
SO OFTEN ON BEHALF OF INTERNET
ASSOCIATION AND WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN
AWESOME ENDED. WE SHARE SOME OF
THE AUTHOR AND SUPPORTERS GOALS
NAMELY INCREASED. AND OUR
CONTENT MODERATION EFFORTS IN
GREATER AWARENESS OF HARMFUL
CONTENT ONLINE TO THAT END OF
MOST COMPANIES RELEASE
INFORMATION AND DATA ABOUT
THEIR EFFORTS MODERATE CONTENT
ON THE PLATFORM ALREADY. ARE
SHE REPLIED EIGHTY SEVEN A
BETTER NEEDS TO MADE CORPS. AND
TO TURNS OUT OFFICE NO REQUIRES
PLATFORM STRIPPER DETAILED
ACCORDING BASIS PROVIDING ONLY
THE NEW. SCALE COME MODERATE
PRACTICE. ALTERED ABOUT HOW CON
AS WELL AND ACTED AGAINST.
PUTTING TOGETHER THIS TRIP AND
DOING TONY WAY THAT WE HAVE A
HIGHLY CON BUT IS ACCURATE AND
CORRECT- WHAT IN THE- WORK
PERIOD TAKES TIME. TO BE NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO REPORT THIS
INFORMATION TO DO NEED TO
REVIEW. ANALYZE ENERGETIC
ACTION. FURTHER THIS VOLUME OF
ARE ARE MAKES IT SOUND LIKE THE-
AND COST TEND TO THE TWO.
PARTICULARLY THE NUMBER TIMES
ACTION ITEMS OF WERE. OR SHARE.
WEBSITE FOR INFORMATION ABOUT A
COMPANY'S TERMS OF SERVICE OR
COMMUNITY GUIDELINES. MOREOVER
ARE COMPANIES BUT GREAT EFFORT
AND RESOURCES AND MAKING THEIR
TERMS OF SERVICE COMMUNITY
GUIDELINES AND TRANSPARENCY
REPORT. ELECT PASSPORT ANYTHING
UNDERSTAND. OUR COMPANIES WANT
USERS TO READ UNDERSTAND THIS
REPORT. TO THAT END MANY
INCORPORATE COLORS COLLAPSIBLE
HEADERS LINKS TO CONTEXTUAL
INFORMATION GRAPHS CHARTS.
THESE POINT LANGUAGE TO
DESCRIBE CONCEPTS AND PRACTICES
AND MORE WHICH ARE ALL DESIGNED
TO INCREASE AWARENESS AND
TRANSPARENCY. BUT HIGHLY
UNLIKELY THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND FAITHFULLY RENDER
THESE FEATURES ON OUR WEBSITE
AND IT'S USEFUL CONTEXT WOULD
BE LOCKED. SO THAT THE
CONCERNED WE SEEM TO A MINIMUM
TRUCKER AN ANNUAL REPORT
BECAUSE THE ON OUR WEBSITE. AND
STRIKE THE REQUIREMENTS
SPECIFIC CONTENT ABOUT COME CON
MODERATION. AND THAT. BUT
CERTAIN THAT SOME. DECISION SIR.
A CONTENT- ARE EASY AND I'M
CONTRA. OTHER TIMES DECISIONS
WERE REVIEWED INDIVIDUAL
CONDUCTING WITH THOSE.
REGARDLESS NEED TO ARE MADE
CONTENT. AND IT CAN FIFTY OF PA.
OF HUNDREDS OF NEW OF PIECES OF
YOUR- ARE SHARED EVERY SINGLE
DAY ACROSS MEDIA PER. I
DECISION ISN'T- COMMITTEE ON
DOING A BEST TO BE A PLACE
IDEAS CHORUS. ALSO ENFORCING
THESE BASIC COMMUNITY CENTER.
THESE REASONS WE WERE. OPPOSE
AB EIGHTY ELEVEN MINUTES LOOK
FOR TO CONTINUE OUR COME. WITH
THE- THANK YOU. THANK NEXT
WITNESS PUT. THANK YOU ARE ABLE
TO MEMBERS ENSURE. CALIFORNIA
CAR AND WE- OPPOSE AB BY THESE
MUST- AREN'T PLACE AN EXTREMELY
HIGH PRIOR ON THE SAME INTO. OF
USER ONLINE. WITH FOR TO CALM
IT HARD CAUGHT. IN SO DOING
BUSINESS TAKE A BACK BASED. TO
CON MONTEREY AND ALL MY COUNTY
AND WORK HARD ENSURE THAT. ARE
AND CONTINUE TO SAFER AND MORE
SO. ARKANSAS WITH AB FIVE
EIGHTY SO A RECORD IN LINE WITH
THIS GOAL WE BELIEVE BILL CAN
BE. FROM ADDITIONAL IMPROVE.
OUT FIRST AS NOTED IN THE
ANALYSIS- THE BILL CAN BENEFIT
FROM CONSIDERATION OF HOW THE
INFORMATION REQUIRED IN THESE
MANDATORY QUARTERLY REPORTS
COULD IN FACT BE EXPLOITED BY
BAD ACTORS. WHO WANT TO
CIRCUMVENT THE COMPANY'S
CONTENT MODERATION PRACTICES
THESE REPORTS REQUIRED
DISCLOSURE OF DETAILED
INFORMATION INCLUDING THINGS
LIKE TRAINING MANUALS AND
DESCRIPTIONS OF AUTOMATED
MODERATION SYSTEMS. THIS
INFORMATION IS SENSITIVE AND
PROVIDES ABOUT ACTORS WITH
DETAILS ABOUT OUR CAPABILITIES
AND BEST PRACTICES THIS IS ALSO
WHY OUR CONCERNS ARE
HEIGHTENED. BY THE NEW
AMENDMENTS WHICH HAVE RAISED
THE DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS
FROM DESCRIPTIONS OF THESE
ITEMS TO COMPLETE AND DETAILED
DESCRIPTIONS OF THE SAME.
SECOND AND ALSO S NOTED IN THE
ANALYSIS ALTHOUGH THE BILL
REQUIRES THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
POLICIES REPORTS ON ITS WEBSITE
IT IS NOT CLEAR WHAT ELSE YOU
TURN GENERAL WILL BE EXPECTED
TO DO WITH THE INFORMATION AND-
REPORTS. THAT'S IN ADDITION TO
THE BURDEN OF POSTING REPORTS
ON A QUARTERLY BASIS AND THE
LEVEL OF DETAILED INFORMATION
DEMANDED THE PURPOSE OF
ACCORDING TO THE AGENCY BECAUSE
ONLINE. IT IS YET UNCLEAR THESE
ARE SOME OF THE REASONS WHY WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE EIGHTY FIVE
EIGHTY SEVEN UNLESS AMENDED I
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY WE HEARD WE LOOK
FORWARD TO. WORKING AT THE
OFFICE OFFICE ON UNRESOLVED
EACH. THANK THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT HIS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
HEARING ROOM UP TO AB FIVE
EIGHTY. SEEING NONE WITH. VIDEO
ROOM. WITH THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
SITE. C. NOT RIGHT OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE OPPOSITION. TO EIGHTY
FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN. Q. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT
FOUR IN Q. WILL WATER INE
EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
ACTUALLY A TYPICAL TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES AND COULDN'T GET
THROUGH IN SUPPORT BUT AT THIS
IS MARC AND BEYOND. THE
COMMONSENSE MEDIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
NEARLY TALKED ON THE APPLE TECH
THAT WE LINE OUR POSITION WITH
THAT OF THE INTERNET THE-
RESPECTFUL OPPOSE AMENDED THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I'M SEVENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS STEPHANIE SILVA
CONCERNED CITIZEN AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU THANK YOU
RIGHT EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
JAMIE HOPPED WITH THE CIVIL
JUSTICE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU. I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU OPERATOR YOU MAY
CLOSE THE LIGHTS ON BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THIS
GALLAGHER. YEAH AND SO I'VE
BEEN TALKING WITH THE AUTHOR A
LOT ABOUT THIS ISSUE- THIS
YEAR'S AS THE COMMITTEE KNOWS I
HAD MY OWN LEGISLATION- THAT
WOULD HAVE APPLIED FIRST
AMENDMENT PROTECTIONS TO SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS- BUT I REALLY
THINK THAT- AND BUT THAT
ULTIMATELY WASN'T SUCCESSFUL- I
THINK ALL TO ME THAT IS WHERE
WE WILL NEED TO GO- BECAUSE
THESE PLATFORMS HAVE BECOME SO-
INSTRUMENTAL THE ARE THE NEW
PUBLIC SQUARE- AND WHERE OUR-
POLITICAL DISCOURSE IS
HAPPENING- MANY THINGS OR
PEOPLE ARE SEEN OUR HEARING ON
THE SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS ARE
HOW- THEY'RE INFLUENCED ON.
VOTING DECISIONS- POLICY
VIEWPOINTS- BUT I DO THINK YOU
KNOW TALK ABOUT THE AUTHOR I
FEEL LIKE THIS IS ACTUALLY THE
FIRST STEP- AND THE FIRST STEP
IS TO REALLY MAKE IT VERY
TRANSPARENT. AS TO WHAT THE
POLICY ACTUALLY IS BECAUSE I
THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T- I
KNOW WHAT THE POLICIES ARE
THERE'S ACCOUNTS THAT ARE
GETTING SUSPENDED OR- AND
WITHOUT PEOPLE EVEN KNOWING
THIS ACTUALLY HAPPENED TO ARE
THE CHAIR OF OUR CALIFORNIA GOP
JESSICA PATTERSON WAS RECENTLY
SUSPENDED. FROM HER TWITTER
ACCOUNT AND STILL HAS GOTTEN NO
EXPLANATION FOR WHY- FOR TWELVE
DAYS WAS NOT ABLE TO GO ONTO
HER TWITTER TWITTER ACCOUNT DO
ANYTHING AND IT'S STILL GOTTEN
NO REAL EXPLANATION FROM
TWITTER- AS TO WHY THIS
HAPPENED THIS IS A PROBLEM YEAH
BECAUSE AGAIN THESE
CONVERSATIONS ARE HAVING A BIG
PART OF OUR POLITICAL.
DISCOURSE IN THIS COUNTRY. AND
IF WE HAVE. ACTORS WHO ARE
SUPPRESSING OR STOPPING SPEECH
AND WE AND THERE'S NO REASON
GIVEN OR OR- NO EXPLANATION FOR
WHY. AND WE CAN'T SEE THAT
THERE'S ANY KID OF CONSISTENCY
AND HOW TERMS OF SERVICE ARE
BEING APPLIED AND ENFORCED I
THINK WE HAVE A VERY SERIOUS
PROBLEM. AND OUR DEMOCRACY SO I
KNOW THAT THE AUTHOR I'VE
TALKED A LOT I WANT TO WORK
WITH HIM ON THIS BILL- AND- YOU
KNOW MAYBE IT WOULD TAKE
SOMEONE ON THE RIGHT AND
SOMEONE ON THE LEFT- FOR REALLY
WORKING TOGETHER AND TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT'S THE RIGHT
PATH HERE. TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE TRANSPARENCY TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE- CONSISTENCY- AND
I THINK IT STARTS BY REALLY.
BRINGING ALL THE STUFF TO LIGHT
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL- IS REALLY ATTEMPTING TO
DO- SO APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
AND I WILL BE SUPPORTING- THE
MEASURE TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU GONZALEZ. I'M A SUPPORT
THIS OF COURSE I AM NOW-
REALIZING THAT. I HAD MULTIPLE
BILLS THAT ARE COMING- PROBES
ON THE SAME SUBJECT SO IT WOULD
BE GREAT I'M JUST GOING TO
REMIND EVERYBODY TO MAYBE GET
TOGETHER AND FIGURE OUT WHAT
WE'RE DOING IN THE SPACE. I'M
SORT OF YOUR ATTENTION. THANK
YOU- QUESTIONS COMMENTS SEEING
NONE MIKLOS AT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WOULD- I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND
THAT MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE STONE AYE STONE
AYE GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER AYE
CHAU CHIU. DAVIES DAVIES I
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I HOLDEN
KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN REYES YES I. THE
BILLS OUT THANK YOU THANK YOU
RIGHT MR LOW YOU HAVE TO ITEMS
WITH THIS AB TEN EIGHTY FOUR
AND AB ELEVEN NINETY FOUR
SHOULD WE GO WITH A V. TEN
EIGHTY FOUR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE COMMITTEES HARD WORK
AND LIKE TO A SEPTIC COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS ON MAKING SURE THAT
WE REMOVE AS MUCH STIGMA AS
POSSIBLE. AND LET TOYS BE TOYS
AND LET KIDS BE KIDS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THANK
YOU I HAVE TWO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT ROB SMITH AND BRITAIN
SIRES. ARE YOU WITH US ON THE
TELEPHONE. ROB SMITH I AM GO
AHEAD PLEASE YES. OKAY GREAT
THANKS FOR INCLUDING ME IN THIS
CONVERSATION AND- FIRST OF ALL
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT ME JUST MY
BACKGROUND I OWN A BRAND CALLED
SALUTE PROJECT RESEARCH WHICH
IS A GENDER NEUTRAL- FASHION
BRAND- AND- BEFORE THAT- I
HISTORY IS I WORKED FOR MACY'S
FOR TWENTY TWO YEARS AMONG
THAT. OVERSEEING MACY'S- BUYING
EMERGED AS FOR KIDS AFTER THAT
I WAS THE CHIEF PRODUCT OFFICER
FOR KIDS GLOBALLY FOR NIKE AND
THE VICE OUT I HAVE A GOOD
EXPERIENCE IN THIS IN THIS
AREA- SO I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
IS THIS BILL AND WHY I BELIEVE
IT'S IMPORTANT ESPECIALLY FOR
LEADERS LIKE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO. TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH THAT- SO IT'S REALLY-
ABOUT TEN MINUTES SO IT WAS UP
TO ME RIGHT NOW I WOULD
INDICATE DEPARTMENT- BECAUSE
KIDS HAVE ALL THE SAME SIZE
BODIES UNTIL THEY APPEAR TO BE
ESSENTIALLY TAKE DOWN WHAT YOUR
GIRL SIGN SO MUCH KIDS SHOP
WITHIN A SHOP AND CURRENT
SHOPPERS OF SUCK BUT THAT'S-
THAT'S A MAJOR MOVE THIS IS.
CREATING A GENERAL SPACES THE
BEGINNING OF THE MOVEMENT AND
REALLY CREATING WHAT I THINK
IS- AS CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO
DO CREATING OUT OF STATE AND
FOR ME SPACE FOR KIDS WHO DON'T
FALL INTO THIS BINARY IDEA OF
WHAT IS TO BE A BOY AND TO BE A
GIRL- IN A RECENT VISIT TO-
MAJOR DEPARTMENT STORE. THE
GIRLS DEPARTMENT ONE TO GIVE
YOU AN IDEA- WHAT IT'S LIKE TO
WALK INTO A GIRL'S FUHRMAN SAYS
ALL YOUR DREAMS SMILE STAY
HAPPY YOU LOVE IS THE WAY BE
COOL BE KIND. OF BOYS CARBON
SAYS LEGEND YOUR AFFECT FUTURE
HERO MAKE TODAY COUNT YOU'LL
CONQUER THE WORLD DUDE SO
WHAT'S HAPPENING- IN DEPARTMENT
STORES AND RETAIL SPACES IS THE
GENDER STEREOTYPES CAUSE
SERIOUS LONG LASTING HARM 60%
PARENTS SAY SO- WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE IS CREATE A
SPACE IN THE MIDDLE AND CREATED
SPACE FOR KIDS TO AND PARENTS
TO- SHOT SAFELY AND SHOP-
WITHOUT GENDER STEREOTYPES- YOU
KNOW IT'S ALREADY HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW BIG BOX RETAILERS
TARGET SHIFTED THEIR ENTIRE.
MERCHANDISING FOR THE TOY
DEPARTMENTS AWAY FROM- GENDER
AND CATEGORY. AND I'M WITH AS A-
FOR A LOT RETAIL. WERE INTO
SPACE. AND WORKING TO FIGURE
OUT AND TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO MAKE A HAPPEN- THE WAY I
LOOK AT IT IS- BY. THIS IT'S
TAX PROBE. IT'S GOING TO KEEP
JOBS IN RETAILERS IN PLACE
BECAUSE THE INTERJECTION IS
MOVING THIS WAY. AND YOU'RE
JUST HELPING- CONVERT CUSTOMERS
WHO WOULD NORMALLY SHOP IN BIG
BOX RETAIL SPACES. WILL MIGRATE
TO DIGITAL ADDRESS A CONSUMER
SPACES AND BUY ONLINE INSTEAD
OF BUYING IN STORES SO. IT'S
NOT JUST THE RIGHT THING TO DO-
SCORE HUMANS BUT IT'S ALSO A
GREAT THING TO DO PROCESS-
THAT'S WHAT AT THE STATE.
APPLICATION QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU. ALSO HAVE BRING SIRED YOU.
GOOD. IN ONE CHAIR MISTER VICE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS AND SHE IN NINE
YEARS OLD YOU MAY KNOW ME
BECAUSE AB. THE FOUR BEGAN IN
MY MIND. SOME OF THE KNOW.
ABOUT L. PLUS RIGHT INTO SOME
OF THIS IS A GENDER AREA AND
GENDER RIGHT. I MEAN MYSELF
FAMILIAR BOTH. AB TWENTY FOUR
WILL LOOK. GENDER NEUTRAL
SECTION AND- STORES. THE TO
FIGURE OUT WHO THEY ARE THE
CHEN I DON'T. HE AND ARE HARD
ENOUGH BOY AND GIRLS SEX TRYING
KIND THEIR IN ON AND ALLOW BOX.
I HOPE KNOW WILL MAKE ALL THE
KIDS YOU KNOW FINANCE SIDE
STOCK. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHTS
SO IS THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
TEN FOUR. SEEING WITNESS VIDEO
ROOM. OR REMOTE TO. SITE SEEING
NONE OPERATOR WE YOU OPEN LINE
FOR OTHERS WHO WOULD LIKE TO OF
FOR A BI TEN EIGHTY FOUR. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TEN EIGHTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND WE DO HAVE TO
IN Q. IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT
FOR THE FIRST LINE THANK YOU.
BY NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU RYAN EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING TAMMY
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA WE DON'T CURRENTLY
HAVE A FORMAL POSITION ON THE
BILL BUT WE VERY MUCH SUPPORT
THE AUTHOR'S INTENT AND GOALS
AND WE REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH AUTHOR HONEST.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU WILL KILL
MEMBERS CONTRACTED WORK. I'M
SORRY GO AHEAD IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. MCCALLUM MCCALLUM
MEDDLESOME TRANSCRIBER I AM
SUPPORTING THE BILL GOT YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
THEN WE WILL MOVE TO OPPOSITION
I HAVE MATTHEW MCREYNOLDS OF
THE PACIFIC JUSTICE INSTITUTE.
YES A GOOD MORNING- CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
MATTHEW MCREYNOLDS SENIOR STAFF
ATTORNEY AT THE PACIFIC JUSTICE
INSTITUTE CENTER FOR PUBLIC
POLICY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. ONE OF THE MAIN REASONS
THAT WE'RE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL IS CONCERNED WITH WHERE
THIS WOULD TAKE THE UNRUH CIVIL
RIGHTS ACT AT YOU TO THIS POINT
OUR LANDMARK CIVIL RIGHTS LAWS
FOCUSED ON DENIAL OF SERVICES-
AS WELL AS COMBINATIONS AND
PRIVILEGES. IN BUSINESS
ESTABLISHMENTS THIS BILL WOULD
DO SOMETHING VERY DIFFERENT
THAN THAT THIS WOULD TAKE THE
ANDREW ACT IN A DIRECTION WHERE
SIGNIFICANT FINES AND
ATTORNEY'S FEES COULD ACCRUE
NOT BECAUSE ANYONE IS DENIED A
SERVICE DENIED THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PURCHASE. THE GOODS THAT
THEY SEEK WAR TO ENTER THE
ESTABLISHMENT THAT THEY SEEK
ISAAC COMMITTEE ANALYSIS POINTS
OUT THERE'S NO EVIDENCE THAT
THAT IS ACTUALLY HAPPENING WHAT
THIS WOULD DO. IS TAKE THE
CIVIL RIGHTS ACT A DIRECTION
WHERE- BY CUSTOMERS SUBJECTIVE
EXPERIENCE OF FEELING
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH THE STORES
LAID. WOULD SUBJECT THAT STORE
TOO ONEROUS PENALTIES AND FINES
AND NOW WE SEE THAT EVEN THE
AND NOTICED PROVISION
OPPORTUNITY. CURE HAS BEEN
REMOVED FROM THE BILL. SECONDLY
HOW WE JUST OUT THE US SUPREME
ADDRESS. A VERY SIMILAR ISSUE
TEN YEARS AGO WHEN THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE HAD
TRIED TO HELP PARENTS- QUOTE
UNQUOTE BY RESTRICTING ACCESS
TO VIDEO GAMES. AND THE US
SUPREME COURT IN BROWN VERSUS
OUR TEAM EMERGENCY SATIATION
STRUCK DOWN THAT ATTEMPT AND
NOTED THAT PARENTS DON'T NEED
THE HELP OF THE LEGISLATURE TO
PICK OUT APPROPRIATE TOYS FOR
THEIR CHILDREN. THERE'S NO
LIMITING PRINCIPLE IN THIS BILL
SO- ONE CAN ONLY GUESS WHERE
IT'LL THE NEXT ALTHOUGH AS ONE
OF THE SUPPORTING WITNESSES
JUST NOTED- SOME IN SUPPORT.
WHICH SUGGESTS THAT EVEN
TELLING KIDS TO FOLLOW THEIR
DREAMS IS DISCRIMINATORY AND
STEREOTYPICAL AND NEEDS TO BE
ELIMINATED SO FOR ALL THESE
REASONS- AND OTHERS WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU THIRTY ONE HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WHO'D LIKE TO
INDICATE OPPOSITION AB TEN
EIGHTY FOUR. SAY NOT ABOUT THE
WITNESS VIDEO ROOM WHERE THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY SAY. SAY NOT
RIGHT OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN
THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO INDICATE OPPOSITION TO
AB TEN EIGHTY FOUR. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TEN EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE ABOUT SHORE IN Q. IT'LL
JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR THE
FIRST COMMENT THANK YOU. I WILL
GO TO ONE SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MISTER SHARON MEMBERS
DEAN GRIFFEY LOW ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION- THE LAST AMENDED
ON A. B. TEN EIGHTY FOUR. LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATION WITH THE AUTHOR
AND THE STAFF THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RIGHT NINETY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES CRAIG BURKE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL IN
THE STRONG OPPOSITION TO AB
PANDEY OR. THANK YOU RIGHT
NINETY ONE PLEASE CALL AT.
EARLIER LAWLERCAPITAL RESEARCH.
I'M OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY TECH.
EIGHTY FOUR. THANK YOU RIGHT
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THINK.
ARAMBULA I THINK GOING OUT
KAMRAN WHATEVER THEY WANT.
INDEPENDENT NOT GOING BROWN BUT
I CAN'T TELL I REGULAR CLIENT
OF THE. I KNOW. IN FACT. I HAVE
A SECOND THERE ARE CONCERNS AND
I AM QUOTING FROM. THANK YOU
THANK YOU AFTER FURTHER COMMENT
THANK YOU AT THIS. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU ARE PRETTY CLOSE
ALLIANCE I DON'T BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. GONZALEZ I DON'T LIKE
WHAT YOU'RE WHERE YOU'RE GOING
WITH THIS BILL I'M A LITTLE
CONCERNED IN MAYBE YOU CAN
EXPLAIN TO ME. IT WOULD SEEM
JUST. AS SOMEBODY WHO SPENT A
LOT OF TIME AND CHILDREN'S
DEPARTMENTS THAT- A LOT
ESPECIALLY THAT EIGHT YEAR OLD
WHO JUST CALLED AND I'M
THINKING OF THAT EIGHT YEAR OLD.
IS THERE A REASON THE GENDER
NEUTRAL SEEMS I GET IT. BUT IS
THERE A REASON WE'RE JUST NOT.
REQUIRING A COMBINATION OF
KIDS. CLOTHES KIDS. TOYS
WITHOUT DESIGNATION BECAUSE I
THINK. THE TOP FIRST STEP- AND
HAVING. HAD DIFFERENT CHILDREN
CHOOSE DIFFERENT THINGS TO WEAR.
THE. THE GENDER NEUTRAL TENDS
TO BE BOYS YEAH BOYISH CLOTHES
FOR GIRLS RIGHT- TRYING TO
SATISFY- FOR EXAMPLE A BOY WHO
WANTS TO WEAR- CLOSE THAT ARE
LABELED AS GIRLS WHETHER IT BE.
KEEN SURE OR DRESS THAT IS MUCH
MORE DIFFICULT BECAUSE OF THE
SIGNAGE AND BECAUSE OF THE
EXPECTATION SO I JUST WANT TO
KNOW YOU LIKE IT IS THIS A ONE
STOP APPROACH OR OR ARE WE- IT
JUST SEEMS TO ME I JUST WAS
LIKE LET'S GET RID OF LABELS
AND WHY WERE ADDED. JUST TO
THINK ABOUT THE FUTURE-
STANDARDIZING SIZES BETWEEN AT
BOYS AND GIRLS CLOTHES AND
SHOES IS A KEY COMPONENT OF ALL
OF THIS BEING ABLE TO KIND OF
WEAR WHAT YOU WANT AND FOR
PARENTS TO BE ABLE TO SHOP
ACCORDINGLY JUST A SUGGESTION
FOR IT MAYBE FUTURE LEGISLATION
BUT I'D LIKE TO KNOW WHAT YOUR
THOUGHT PROCESS AND- CREATING A
GENDER NEUTRAL CATEGORY RATHER
THAN JUST SAYING LET'S GET RID
OF. THE BOYS AND GIRLS I'LL-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF SOMEONE
AT. AS YOU MAY KNOW I SPENT IT-
QUITE SOME TIME MEETING WITH
THE RETAILERS AND LEARNING
ABOUT. AND HEARING FROM
DIFFERENT SPECIALTIES IN THE-
NUANCE ABOUT HOW THEY WOULD
ORGANIZED A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES. OF WHAT YOU'RE
SUGGESTING IS SOMETHING THAT I
THINK WOULD LIKE TO GO TO IN
THE SPIRIT AND INTENT. OF WHAT
YOU'RE DISCUSSING- BUT THE BILL
THAT WE HAVE IS TRYING TO NOT
BE SO PRESCRIPTIVE TO ALLOW
FOR. THE RETAILERS TO DO WHAT
THEY ALREADY ARE DOING- THE
BILL BEFORE US DOESN'T CHANGE
ANYTHING. THIS APPLIES TO FIVE
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES OR MORE THERE
ARE DOING IT BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FIFEEN. SO THEY
TEND TO TRY TO NOT BE TOO
PRESCRIPTIVE BUT I SHARE WITH
YOU THE DESIRE THAT YOU HAVE
SPECIFICALLY. I'M JUST ALLOWING
FOR THE INDIVIDUAL AND THE
CONSUMER TO MAKE THE CHOICE
ACCORDINGLY AND AN ORGANIZED
FASHION SO I SHARE THAT- BUT-
THE BILL BEFORE SO IS TO TRY TO
ATTEMPT TO NOT BE. TOO
PRESCRIPTIVE AND JUST ALLOW FOR
THE INDIVIDUAL RETAILER TO
ORGANIZE ACCORDINGLY AS WE SEEK
TO SELF IT. THANK YOU OTHER
QUESTIONS CURRENT. SEEING NONE
WESTERLY MAY CLOSE AT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK
YOU I AM LOOKING FOR MOTION.
THANK YOU IN A SECOND. THE
SECOND THANK YOU THE MOST IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER NO CHAU.
CHIU DAVIES. DAVIES NO GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN KALRA. KALRA
AYE KILEY KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN
REYES HI BASED ON. THIRTIES TO
MORE SO PLACE THE BILL ON CALL.
AND THEN ITEM NUMBER NINE R.
ITEM NINE AB ELEVEN NINETY FOUR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
COLLEAGUES AGAIN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TO THE COMMITTEE STAFFER
ALSO HELPING TO WORK ON THIS
POLICY ISSUE AND WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS AS WELL.
AS THE CHAIR OF THE BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE AND
OVERSEEING THE PROFESSIONAL
FISHERS PEARLS LONG AS THE
DAIRY OF JURISDICTION HERE IN
THIS COMMITTEE- HOPING TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION FOR
THE RESPECTIVE ENTITIES AND
PROVIDE TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE. THANK YOU I HAVE ONE
SUPPORT WITNESS LISTED BRANDON
HAAS OF THE GLOBAL GLOBAL LEGAL
LAW FIRM. ARE YOU WITH US ON
THE PHONE. I AM CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES GO AHEAD PLEASE- THANK YOU
FORMOSA I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
GOD I'M MY NAME IS BRANDON-
SAAD AND- I WORK FOR A LARGE
GLOBAL LARGE- LAW FIRM- CANCER
GRADUATE TO MASTER'S DEGREES.
YET I HAVE BEEN DECIMATED BY A-
CONSERVATORSHIP THAT ACTING IN
THE BEST INTEREST OF MY
PARENTS- FIRST I'D LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT MY DEEPEST GRATITUDE
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW ADDED
DYNAMIC. DATA FOR ADDRESSING
THIS HIDDEN CRIME-
UNFORTUNATELY. MY LIFE AND MY
PARENTS LIVE WERE RUINED BY A
CONSERVATIVE- THAT. THIS OLDER
LIFESAVING. SOLD THEIR HOUSE.
THROUGH MY MOTHER IN A NURSING
HOME- AGAINST HER WILL IN
ADVANCE DIRECTIVES. BOWL HOME
AND IRATE OF WHICH THE MONEY
WAS TAKEN OUR- SHIELDED FOR
MEDICAID APPROVAL THE
CONSERVATIVE COULD HAVE EASILY
SHIELDED ALL OF HER LIFE AB ALL
THEIR LIFE SAVINGS AND THE HOME
THAT MAINTAIN THE LARGEST NON
CASH ASSET YET. HE SIMPLY
DECIDE TO IGNORE THE LAW AND
SELL OFF THEIR ASSETS. MY
PARENTS AFTER EIGHTY YEARS HAVE
NERO LIFESAVING AND ARE ON
MEDICAID- IT IS CRITICAL THAT
WE HAVE ACCOUNTABILITY
TRANSPARENCY AND STRONGER
OVERSIGHT OR WHAT THE
CONSERVATIVES ARE DOING LARGELY
THE COURT APPOINTED-
CONSPIRATORS. IT IS. THE OVER
ARCHING SYSTEM THAT MUST BE
REFORM AND AGING GREATER
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN THE
DIVISIONS OF THE TOPIC DU JERRY
A PROFESSIONAL TO DO HEARING
EURO OF. UNBELIEVABLY WHAT I
WANT TO STANFORD I HAVE
ATTENDED LAW SCHOOL I HAVE
ANOTHER MASTER'S DEGREE WHEN I
FILED THE LAWSUIT AGAINST THE
CONSERVATIVE- HE USES. MY
PARENTS OWN MONEY TO HIRE A
LAWYER FOR HIM. SO BECAUSE I'VE
BEEN SPENDING ALL MY MONEY ON
MY PARENTS THEY DON'T HAVE ANY
MORE A WAR SPENDING I CAN'T
AFFORD AN ATTORNEY TO REPRESENT
IS- LACK OF COULD YOU SHARE
RESPONSIBILITY. FORCED MY
PARENTS YET USES MY PARENTS OWN
MONEY TO HIRE HIM AN ATTORNEY
THIS IS- IT'S UNBELIEVABLE IT'S
HIDDEN NOT. VERY MANY PEOPLE
ARE AWARE OF THE CAMPBELL OF
PROFESSIONALS THAT ARE INVOLVED
IN THIS- I AGAIN JUST WANT THEM.
LANDMINES STRONGER SUPPORT- AB.
ONE ONE NINE FOUR. NINE FOUR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. RIGHT IS
IT ANYONE HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WHO'D LIKE TO INDICATE
SUPPORT FOR A BI ONE ONE NINE
FOUR. RIGHT SEE NOT HAVE AT THE
WITNESS VIDEO ROOM FOR THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY SITE. SEEING
NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN
THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR AB
ELEVEN NINETY FOUR. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB ELEVEN NINETY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND I DO HAVE ABOUT SIX
IN Q. WILL GO TO LINE ONE ON
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS
RICHARD CALHOUN WITH CEDAR
COALITION OF ELDER AND
DISABILITY RIGHT STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF ELEVEN NINETY FOUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARE IS BE
ONE MOMENT FOR THE NEXT COMMENT.
RYAN WON ALL FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ASHLEY
PERFECTLY WRITTEN IN THEM AND I
SUPPORT EIGHTY DASH. ONE ONE
NINE FOUR. THANK YOU RIGHT WHY
DON'T YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MORNING THIS IS TONY CHICKEN
SALAD CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES FOR
NURSING HOME REFORM IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I NINETY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI KEVIN
WILL WITH THE FREE PRETTY
MOVEMENT CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
AB. ELEVEN NINETY FOUR. THANK
YOU I NINETY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS CODY I
AM CONCERNED THAT OFFEND
COLLEEN IN SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN
NINETY FOUR THE CONSERVATORSHIP
LOT ARE BROKEN AND WE NEED
REFORM PLEASE VOTE YES. THANK
YOU LINE SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI- TRICIA FROM THE PRE
BRITNEY MOVEMENT AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
WE WILL MOVE OPPOSITION I HAVE
NONE LISTED IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WHO'D LIKE TO.
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
ELEVEN NINETY FOUR. SEEING NONE
WITNESS VIDEO ROOM OR THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY SITE. SEEING
NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN
THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB OR. ELEVEN NINETY FOUR. IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF AB ELEVEN NINETY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND MORE TO LINE TWENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT
CHAIRED MEMBERS THIS IS JERRY
DEATH MAN ON BEHALF OF THE
PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA. THE
FACT IS WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HELLO ON
SEVERAL ISSUES AT THE MEASURE
TO SUPPORT AND WE DO NOT HAVE
BEEN OPPOSE POSITION ON THE
BILL BUT THOUGHT THIS WOULD BE
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. TO
COMMENT. BACK STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE INTENT OF THE BILL AS WELL
THE EXISTING LAW TO PROTECT THE
BEST INTERESTS OF CONSERVATIVES
AND WARDS. THEY'RE BUILT
INTERESTS REMAIN PARAMOUNT AND
ARE THE BASIS UPON WHICH OUR
ASSOCIATION CO SPONSORED THE
LEGISLATION ESTABLISHING STATE
LICENSING BUREAU. TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS THROUGH LICENSING
EDUCATION ENFORCEMENT OF THE
ACT. AT THE EFFORT IS MADE
THROUGH AB ELEVEN NINETY FOUR
TO ENHANCE AND ADD TO THE
PROTECTIONS IN EXISTING LAW. IT
IS IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THE
FUNDAMENTAL ROLE
RESPONSIBILITIES AND JUDGMENT
OF THE COURTS ON THESE ISSUES
AND TO ENSURE THAT NEW
REQUIREMENTS WILL BE EFFECTIVE
IN FURTHERING THE PROTECTIONS
OF DESIRE. WE'RE OPTIMISTIC
THAT THESE COULD BE ACHIEVED
AND LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
OUR GATE SPENT ON A BI LEVEL
NINETY FOUR AS A PER STATE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MIGHT WANT TO WAIT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS HELENE BALLOT
OFF WITH THE CONSERVATORSHIP
REFORM PROJECT AND WE SUPPORT
AB ELEVEN NINETY FOUR AND WE
HOPE THIS IS THE FIRST OF AS
MANY STEPS AS IT TAKES TO
REFORM THANK YOU
CONSERVATORSHIP I'M SORRY WE'RE
NOT TAKING ANY MORE TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT THIS IS FOR.
OPPOSITION BUT WE WILL NOTE
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU I HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
I'M PRETTY THEM A CLOSE ALLY.
OF RESPECTED COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. THANK YOU
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND MISTER LUCKY MAY CLOSE
AT THANK YOU AGAIN TO THE CHAIR
AND THIS COMMITTEE FOR
PARTNERING ON THERE IS A
JURISDICTION ON REFORM
CONSERVATIVE SHIPS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND
SECOND THAT MOTION IS DUE
PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER AYE CHAU.
CHIU DAVIES GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
HOLDEN KALRA HI KALRA AYE KILEY
AYE KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN REYES
HI CHRIS I. THE BILLS OUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU READ
THE BRINGS US TO ITEM NUMBER
TEN AB TWO FIFTY EIGHT MR VIA
SILVA. MORNING MORE TAKE A
CHAIR MEMBERS. AB TWO FIFTY
EIGHT. SIX TO ADDRESS THE UNMET
NEEDS AND CHALLENGES TO HOUSE
AND WHOLE THE HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR PETS
ESPECIALLY DURING. EMERGENCIES
LIKE COVE IN NINETEEN PET
ADDICT. A PET IS A SOURCE OF
COURAGE STRENGTH AND LOVE FOR
SOMEONE STRUGGLING TO SURVIVE
UNFORTUNATELY MOST HOMELESS
SHELTERS HAVE NO PET POLICIES
WHICH IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
BARRIERS THAT KEEP HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS. AWAY FROM SHELTERS.
LEADING MANY MANY HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS TO REMAIN OUT IN
THE STREETS. AB TWO FIVE TWO
FIVE EIGHT WILL REQUIRE. WE
REQUIRE ANY STATE FUNDED INTRUM
HOUSING OR SHELTER TO FOLLOW
THE LOW BARRIER NAVIGATION
CENTER MODEL. WITH WHAT WHICH
WOULD REMOVE BARRIERS TO ENTER-
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS AB TWO
FIVE EIGHT WILL ALSO ENCOURAGE
SHELTERS TO PARTNER WITH LOCAL
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS THAT
MAY BE ABLE TO HELP PROVIDE
FOOD AND VETERINARY SERVICES IN
ORDER AND IN ORDER TO SHELTERS
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR
PETS. WITH ME TODAY. IS
CHRISTOPHER MARTIN POLICY
DIRECTOR AT THE AT THE HOUSING
CALIFORNIA AND JILL ANTHONY
DIRECTOR OF THE ANIMAL
PROTECTION LEAGUE TO ROCK TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY TODAY. THANK
YOU THANK YOU WE DO A MOTION
AND A SECOND SO I DO HAVE TO
SUPPORT WITNESSES CHRISTOPHER
MARTIN AND JOE ANTHONY
CHRISTOPHER MARTIN ARE YOU WITH
US. HI CHERYL AHEAD PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CHRISTOPHER
MARTIN AND I'M THE POLICY
DIRECTOR AT HOUSING CALIFORNIA
AN ADVOCACY NONPROFIT FOCUSED
ON ENSURING ALL CALIFORNIANS
HAVE THE STATE STABLE AND
AFFORDABLE PLACE TO CALL HOME.
CALIFORNIA IS FACING AN
UNPRECEDENTED CRISIS WITH OVER
A HUNDRED FIFTY ONE THOUSAND
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ON ANY GIVEN
NIGHT. HUNDRED SIXTEEN THOUSAND
OF WHICH ARE EXPERIENCING
UNSHELTERED HOMELESSNESS. WHICH
TOTALED OVER HALF OF OUR NATION
UNSHELTERED POPULATION.
RESPONDING EFFECTIVELY TO
HOMELESSNESS REQUIRES A
COMBINATION OF STRATEGIES
PREVENTING OR DIVERTING PEOPLE
FROM EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
WHENEVER POSSIBLE ENSURING
PEOPLE HAVE. TRANSITION RAPIDLY
FROM HOMELESSNESS TO HOUSING
AND SERVICES AND PROVIDING
IMMEDIATE LOW BARRIER SHELTER
OPTIONS TO PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS WHO CAN NOT
IMMEDIATELY ACCESS. PERMANENT
HOUSING EMERGENCY SHELTER
SHOULD SUPPORT HELLO FROM
HOUSING CRISIS TO HOUSING
STABILITY UNFORTUNATELY HIGH
BARRIERS TO ENTRY TO EMERGENCY
SHELTER OR INTERN HOUSING
PROHIBIT FLOW THROUGH THE
SYSTEM AN ACT THAT THE
SERVICES. IF KEPT RECEIVED AN
EMERGENCY SHELTER STAY REQUIRES
CONFORMING TO ARBITRARY RULES
OR EXPECTATIONS THAT SEEM
UNREASONABLE PUNITIVE OR THAT
DIVIDE THEM FROM THERE TO FIND
FAMILY THEY MAY DECLINE THE
SUPPORT THEY DESPERATELY NEED.
FOR EMERGENCY SHELTER TO
ACHIEVE ITS INTENDED PURPOSES
THE EXPECTATION PLAY THANK GOD
SHOULD BE MINIMAL TRANSPARENT
AND REASONABLE LOW BARRIER
SHELTERS EMPATHIZE WELCOMING
GUESTS IN AS THEY ARE WHILE
HAVING CLEAR AND SIMPLE
BEHAVIORAL EXPECTATIONS. THAT
APPLY TO ANYBODY RESIDING IN
THAT SHELTER THESE EXPECTATIONS
ARE NEARLY FOCUSED ON
MAINTAINING A SAFE ENVIRONMENT
FOR ALL. IT'S NOT THIS MODEL IS
CALLED THE NAVIGATION CENTER
MODEL. AT THE NAVIGATION CENTER
CLIENTS ARE ALLOWED TO HAVE
PETS LIVE THE LIVE WITH THEIR
PARTNER STORE THEIR PROPERTY
INCOMING ULTIMATELY IN ADDITION
THE CENTER OFFERS ROUND THE
CLOCK CASE MANAGEMENT MENTAL
BEHAVIOR HEALTH SERVICES. AND
CONNECTIONS THE BENEFIT
PROGRAMS THAT HOUSING ALL IN
ONE LOCATION. BY REQUIRING
RECIPIENTS OF STATE FUNDED
PROGRAMS TO FOLLOW THE LOW
BARRIER MODEL EIGHTY TWO FIFTY
EIGHT WILL CREATE A SYSTEM FOR
ALL REGARDLESS OF PRECONDITION
FOR AND PROVIDE THEM ACCESS TO
SHELTER ON THEIR WAY TOWARDS
FINDING STABILITY INTERNET
HOPPING. I WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR PROPOSING
THIS CRITICAL LET LEGISLATION
AND HOW THEY CALIFORNIA IS
PROUD TO SUPPORT. ENERGY YOUR
EYES OUT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
JOANNE GOOD MORNING CARE FOUND
A MEMBERS OF THE ON JUDICIARY
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO FIFTY EIGHT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DON'T COULD LAW MY NAME
IS JOANNE SWEENEY I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF DEVELOPMENT AND
COMMUNITY OUTREACH FOR THE
ANIMAL PROTECTION LEAGUE BASED
OUT OF TALKING CALIFORNIA AND
SERVING ALL OF GALAXY COUNTY I
AM HERE TODAY INFO AT EIGHTY
TWO FIFTY EIGHT. THE BILL WAS
WRITTEN AND THEN DOORS WITH
PLASTIC CHAIRS AND FIRST HAND
EXPERIENCES FROM WORKING IN THE
TRENCHES BUT THE HOMELESS AND
THEIR PETS IN MARCH OF TWENTY
TWENTY IN THE BEGINNING STAGES
OF A GLOBAL PANDEMIC I WAS
INVITED TO COME LOOK AT THE
CONDITION OF SOME ANIMALS OUT
AT A HOMELESS CAMP TO DATE I
HAVE BEEN VISITING THESE COUNTS
UP TO FIVE TIMES A WEEK. EVERY
WEEK EVER SINCE. DURING THE-
YEAR CONDITION I HAVE. FOR BOTH
PEOPLE AND PETS UTTERLY FOR
MEDICAL SH I HAVE WATCHED THE
NUMBER OF HOMES CONTINUE TO
GROW RIGHT ALONG WITH THEIR
FURRY COMPANIONS AND A NUMBER
THAT DEFIES COMPREHENSION. THAT
COULD CHANGE AND MONTHS OF
BEING DENIED ANY HELP FROM THE
ANIMAL CONTROL. THE ANIMAL
PROTECTION LAKE AND THE SAKE
HOMELESS SHELTER. FUNDED BY THE
UNITED WAY AND THE CITY OF
STOCKTON PARTNER TOGETHER AND
CREATED A PILOT PROGRAM. THE
PILOT PROGRAM ALLOWED A
HOMELESS INDIVIDUAL TO BE
ACCOMPANIED BY ONE HEAD. INTO A
LOW BARRIER SHELTER AND ANIMAL
PROTECTION LEAGUE PROVIDED FOOD
FOR THE PET VAN NEUTER BATTING
ACTIVATIONS AND ANY ADDITIONAL
VETERINARY NEEDS. DURING THEIR
STAY AT THE HOMELESS SHELTER.
THIS PILOT PROGRAM HAS ENABLED
PEOPLE AND THEIR PETS TO BE IN
A STABLE ENVIRONMENT ANDEVEN
OPEN THE DOOR FOR THE HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS TO SEEK EMPLOYMENT.
FOR EXAMPLE MY NEW FRIEND
VERONICA WAS ABLE TO START HER
NEW LIFE BECAUSE THE PILOT
PROGRAM. FOR ANNIKA HAS
REUNITED WITH YOUR FAMILY AND
SPEND YOUR DAY TURNING AND JOB
APPLICATIONS WITH THE PEACE OF
MIND THAT HER BELONGINGS ARE
NOT BEING STOLEN AND HER DOG
ROXY. IS HOME SAFE. HOMELESS
SHELTERS AND LOCAL ANIMAL
NONPROFITS ACROSS THE STATE.
CAN RECREATE THE SAME OUTCOME.
AB TO PAY EIGHT OVER ALL STATE
HOW AND- PROGRAMS TO FIND IN
TERMS HOUSING TO FOLLOW LOW
BARRIER HOUSING FIRST
PRACTICES. WHICH WILL REMOVE
THE BARRIERS MANY HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS FACE WHEN ACCESSING
SHELTER. I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BILL COULD
OFFER INTERVIEWS IN THIS
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION
I PROBABLY SUPPORT AB TWO FIFTY
EIGHT. AND URGE YOUR IPHONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYONE HERE IN HEARING ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO FIFTY EIGHT. SEEING
NONE ABOUT THE- VIDEO WITNESS
ROOM OR THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
SAY. SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD
YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE
SUPPORT FOR AB. TWO FIFTY
EIGHT. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO FIVE EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND OVER TO LINE
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORNING
SURE MEMBERS IMPACTING THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU WE WILL
THEN MOVED OPPOSITION I HAVE NO
SPECIFIC OPPOSITION WITNESS
LISTED IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY
TWO FIFTY EIGHT. SEEN ON HOW
ABOUT THE VIDEO WITNESS ROOM OR
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY SITE.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WHICH YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR A B. TWO
FIFTY EIGHT ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO INDICATE OPPOSITION.
YOUR FIRST WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWO FIVE EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. NINE SEVENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. THAT
WHAT IF. NINETY FIVE. I'M SORRY
WE COULD BARELY HEAR THAT COULD
YOU SAY THAT AGAIN PLEASE. ALL
THANK YOU FOR WHAT. HI BOTH THE
BILL OKAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU OPERATOR YOU CAN CLOSE THE
LINES BRING IT BACK QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE THIS REVIEW FOR A-
YEAH OF THE DRESS. THANK YOU I
LIKE THE BILL I LIKE THE FACT
THAT WE'RE PROVIDING SOMETHING
FOR SOMEONE WHO'S LOST
EVERYTHING I WILL TELL YOU THAT
WE'VE HAD GREAT SUCCESSES IN
FIGHTING HOUSING FOR MANY ON
HOUSING HOMELESS THE ONE CASE
WAS OUR VETERAN WHO HAD TWO
DOGS AND WE WERE ABLE TO FIND A
PLACE FOR HIM BUT THEY WOULD
NOT TAKE HIS DOGS. AND SO HE
REMAINS TO THIS DAY AND HOUSED
SO I APPRECIATE THE BILL THAT
YOU BROUGHT FORWARD FOR MEMBERS.
YEAH I MEAN I- I'VE SEEN JILL
ANTONINI WHO IS ONE OF OUR WHEN
THIS. HAVE BEEN OUT THERE
WALKING WITH HER AND SHE IS.
YOU KNOW SHE DOES THIS OUT OF
HER BIG HEART TO HELP. AND THE-
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO HIT A HOME
RUN WORD WORD REALLY TRYING TO
JUST GET ON BASE YOU KNOW HIT
THESE LITTLE BITES AND SHE'S.
I'VE BEEN WATCHING HER AND WHAT
SHE'S TO DO TRYING TO DO IN OUR
COMMUNITY BUT THIS IS SOMETHING
I I'VE REALLY. REALLY FEEL
STRONGLY IS NIGHT. IT IT GROWS
ACROSS THE BOARD AND ACROSS THE
STATE. THAT IF WE CAN HELP.
THOSE WHO ARE TRYING TO GET IN
THEY WON'T LEAVE THEIR DOG THEY
WON'T LEAVE THEIR HAT. IT'S
PART OF THEIR FAMILY- AND- IF
WE CAN HELP THAT PERCENTAGE TO-
THEN WE WILL HIT A HOME RUN. SO
I JUST WANT TO THANK- THE CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. REPORT HONEST THAT
ASPERGER STRICTLY ASPEN I VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. RIGHT AS YOU PUT A I
THINK THAT IS YOUR CLOSE. SUR
THANK YOU WE DO A MOTION AND A
SECOND. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS KALRA PLEASE
STONE HI STONE AYE GALLAGHER.
CHAO CHIU. DAVIES DAVIES I
GONZALEZ. CONSULT AYE HOLDEN
ALL RIGT KALRA AYE KILEY KILEY
I'D MAIENSCHEIN REYES RECYCLING.
THE BILLS OUT THANK YOU THANKS
JOHN THANK YOU RATES I REMEMBER
SEVEN WILL GO TO MISS GONZALEZ
AB TWO FIFTY SEVEN. OKAY SO
YOU'RE GONNA PRESENT ALSO A. B.
FOURTEEN SIXTY SEVEN. OKAY SO-
YOU COULD. TAKE WHICHEVER ONE
YOU LIKE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB TWO FIFTY
SEVEN BEGINS TO ADDRESS LONG
STANDING ISSUES IN A FAST FOOD
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY THROUGH THE
CREATION OF A STATE WIDE FAST
FOOD SECTOR COUNCIL BY HOLDING
EMPLOYERS ACCOUNTABLE FOR
PROTECTING THEIR WORKERS WHEN
KNOWLEDGE THE ANALYSIS AND I
WANT TO APOLOGIZE FOR ALWAYS
SAYING WHATEVER WORKER. IT
TRYING TO MAKE LAWS TO IMPROVE
THEIR CONDITIONS ARE IN THE WAR
STATE POSSIBLE AND I AGREE ALL
LOW WAGE WORKERS. ACTUALLY FACE
THESE ISSUES ON THE JOB AT THIS
PARTICULARLY DEALS WITH FAST
FOOD WORKERS. WHO ALSO HAVE.
THESE CHALLENGES- IN THE SAME
DEGREE AS OTHER VERY LOW WAGE
SERVICE WORKERS. DESPITE
WORKING THE FASTEST GROWING
SECTOR IN THE STATE FAST FOOD
WORKERS EXPERIENCE SOME OF THE
LOWEST WAGES. SOME OF THE
LOWEST WAGES ALONG WITH WAGE
THEFT HARASSMENT UNSAFE WORKING
CONDITIONS. THE PANDEMIC IS
ONLY FURTHER MAGNIFIED THE
SYSTEMIC ISSUES. WITH THE
NUMEROUS FROM KOBE NINETEEN
NUMBERS LAWS AND REGULATIONS
WERE. INSTITUTED TO TRY TO
PROTECT WORKERS FROM INFECTION
AND ALLOW THEM TO STAY SAFE AND
RECOVER WITHOUT FEAR OF LOSING
THEIR LIVELIHOODS. HOWEVER
EMPLOYERS HAVE FAILED TO INFORM
THEIR WORKERS ABOUT THESE RIGHT
TO PRESSURE EMPLOYEES TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN WORKING IN UNSAFE
CONDITIONS LOSING THEIR
LIVELIHOODS. WORKERS HAVE
FAILED NUMEROUS COMPLAINTS
DOCUMENTED VIOLATIONS OF COVERT
SAFETY MEASURES PUBLIC HEALTH
LAWS AND LABOR LAWS AND THEY'RE
WINNING THEM. IN ONE NOTABLE
EXAMPLE OF FAST FOOD FRANCHISEE
IN LOS ANGELES ILLEGALLY FIRED
FOUR EMPLOYEES WHO PROTESTED
WORKPLACE CONDITIONS OR UNSAFE.
FOR MANAGING THE SPREAD CODED.
WE KNOW THINGS ARE GETTING
BETTER WITH CO ED AND OBVIOUSLY
OUR RATES ARE ARE EXTREMELY LOW
OW THANK GOD- BUT THAT DOESN'T
CHANGE THE CONDITIONS IN THE
FAST FOOD INDUSTRY
UNFORTUNATELY. AT IT WE NEED TO
CREATE A NEW NORMAL WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT THE INEQUITIES
THAT WE SAW THAT EXISTED PRIOR
TO THE PANDEMIC THAT WERE-
AMPLIFIED DURING THE PANDEMIC.
AND THAT COMING OUT THE
PANDEMIC WE SAID WE WOULD DO
BETTER BY WORKERS THIS IS ONE
OF THOSE SITUATIONS. BY FAR
THESE WORKERS HAVE BEEN
ESSENTIAL FRONTLINE WORKERS
HAVE CONTINUED TO FEED US.
DESPITE BEING IN CONDITIONS
THAT WERE LEFT LARGELY UNSAFE
ARE OFTEN AND SAFE. AND- BEING
LOW PAID. BUT THIS. BILL WILL
ALLOW THEM TO ACTUALLY HAVE A
VOICE ON THE JOB WILL PROTECT
THEM FROM RETALIATION BY
UTILIZING- THE TYPE OF LAWS
THAT HAVE BEEN CREATED OR THEY
WILL CREATE IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
SAFETY AND GOOD WORKING
CONDITIONS. AND IT WILL
CONTINUE TO IMPROVE- AN
INDUSTRY THAT IS NOT SMALL
BUSINESSES BUT IN FACT IS
OPERATED BY LARGE BILLIONAIRE
CORPORATIONS. THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
HOPING TO DO WITH THIS AND WE
HOPE TO GIVE WORKERS A
MEANINGFUL VOICE ON THE JOB IN
A WAY THAT WE'VE NEVER SEEN IN
CALIFORNIA IN THIS INDUSTRY. I
WITNESSES HERE INCLUDING A FAST
FOOD WORKER FROM SAN JOSE MEDIA
RELEASE. THANK YOU. WE DO HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND EMILY
THERE ARE AMENDMENTS LISTED IN.
THE COURSE I WILL ACCEPT THAT
MEDICAID AS A THANK YOU AND AS
USUAL I THINK YOUR STAFF ARE
DOING PHENOMENAL WORK. THANK
YOU RIGHT I HAVE MARIA RUIZ
WITH US ON THE TELEPHONE WITH
THE TRANSLATOR AND SUBA WHERE
HE'D FROM THE UCLA LABOR
CENTER. BOTH WITH US ON THE
PHONE MARIA RUIZ ARE YOU ARE
YOU HERE. CHECK GO TO MARDI.
ONE OF THE. ONE OF THE ANY
NUMBER OF MONEY OUT WE HELLO MY
LAN IN SAN ST UNIT WHEN I CHECK
A FEW THINGS IN THE FACT. THE
MORNING MY NAME IS NADIA WE-
AND I'M NOT GOING WORK AT OF A-
IN A NINETY DAY IF I KEEP THE
IN A YEAR. I'VE BEEN YOU FELT
BY MANY OF YOUR- HOW WE NOT BE.
QUESTION IN MY- NO THEN NOTHING
AND LOOK HE BACK BECAUSE-
MAPPED OUT I WANT TO. YOU TO
PICK THEM. I DID BEGIN NOT
DEPEND ANY I AT A COUPLE OFFICE.
NANDANA WHAT WE LACK OF THE
LIKE MY GO UP. THANK YOU.
EIGHTEEN NOTHING HAVE NOT
FINANCIAL MUFFLED NEW LONDON
THE FEW WILSHIRE THE END OF THE
MONTH AFTER. I LET THE FANS
FACT THIS CALL THE THIRTIETH
DIED IN THE STATE. YOU KNOW
WHAT IF WE CAN OF THE THAT MY
MOM A COOL DEAL LOOK AT MY LOOK
AT THERE LAPTOP THAT IF YOU
LOOK AT THE. HE SAID HE DID NOT
GIVE. NOT GONNA BY ANY. PLAINLY
I HOW DO YOU THE WRONG COPY POT
INDICATES. IF THE PHONE RANG SO
DOES HE LOOK AT WELL ON THE
BOTTOM AND WILL NOT AFFECT THE
APPEARANCE. WHAT THE BEST VALUE
INFO THE IN THE I TAPPED BEEN
NEARLY SEVENTY YEARS WALKING
THE NIGHT GONNA. MEDICALLY NEED
DENTAL EASILY HAPPENS POINT OF
YEARS. ANY COSTA. MEDICAL
AFTERNOON IN FARGO DO YOU HAVE
A I THANK YOU IT BUT IF YOU
DON'T GO THAT IN ONE OF THE
SUCH MAY HAVE THE PEOPLE THE
MOMENT ON THE CARD. BUT I'D
LIKE TO START. BY HOW THEY TRY
TO SILENCE MY VOICE I WAS NOT
SURPRISED. IF YOU NEED ANYTHING
LET ME THAT ABOUT THE THAT IT
DIESEL EQUIPMENT BUT IT'S OFTEN
THE PENSIONS AND I'M JUST
PUTTING MY THOUGHTS. YOU CAN
ALSO SEE IF THE POIGNANT AND
WILL NOT WILL BE THAT A LOCAL
EXPERIENCE. NINE YET FIVE FOOT.
I IT. PLAY THAT BECAUSE OR AT.
YOU DON'T NEED TO. WELCOME OF
CUSTOMER STATES. HOLLY NINETEEN
WILL NOT ONLY BE NOTHING SYMBOL
FAR CALIFORNIA ANTHONY LOOKING
TO THAT YOU CAN LISTEN WITH THE
FUNCTION WITHOUT MORE. SORRY
NINETEEN IT'S- THEY GIVE THE
LATEST CORRECTED WHAT ACROSS
THE STATE WITHOUT OUR BE HEARD
BY I WOULD. IN GOING ON RIGHT
TO TRY AND WIN DATE OF BIRTH
YOUR BACK UP WHAT. BOB DOLE
THINK WENT BY SEE IT THEY IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE TO AFTER LOOKING YOU
FOR THE- I. BUT I NEED YOUR
NEED ON THE- IS A COMMUNE
MEETING POLITICAL. AB FIFTY
SEVEN YOU CAN IMPORTANT STEP
TOWARD WINNING WE ARE FIVE FOR.
ON FAST TO WORK IN CALIFORNIA.
I CALLED THAT IT UP FOR YOU I'M
ABLE TO USE THE PEOPLE THEY SEE
A IT IF LOOK IN A MORE. BLOCKS
LOCAL FINAL ALREADY. WE ARE
LOOKING AT IT. REPUBLICAN
ALMOST FIVE YOU LOOK IN A
STATEMENT. ALSO IN THE
PHARMACOGNOSY IN FIFTH ELEVEN
BILLION OKAY FIFTEEN GLOBAL OF
IF THIS IDEA FUND A LOT MORE.
IT TWELFTH WE THE BOOKING. OF
GETTING PAID. WELL WE ARE-
HARASSED FROM CLOSE TO IT I
FEEL SO MOUNTAIN IDEA ANY. THAT
IDEA IN THE WHEN WE SB UP. ONE
OF THE TWO SEVEN WITH SOME OF
THE ORG IF YOU BEEN VERY THOSE
TOLD YOU TO WHAT THE FIGHTING
I'M UP ON PRESENTS WHO FEEL OF
THE MOST PROGRAM AFTER. ON. WE
KNOW THAT GOES ON BEHIND
ACCOUNT. IN THE- WE- AND WE
NEED. TO THE- DAY. CALLED THE
SOLUTION. TO THE EAST. WE. WHEN
YOU HAVE A FEEL LIKE.
MISSISSIPPI ARE BEEN ABLE WITH
PEOPLE THEY SEE IT. WHAT FAST
FOOD WORKERS NEED AB TWO. SEVEN
BUT I'M OKAY WHAT THE- LAST
YEAR. WE HOPE YOU WILL VOTE
INTO PLACE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
I ALSO SOME- HE- THANK YOU ON
TO AND MA'AM. MY IS THAT PUBLIC
AND I AND THE RETURN DIRECTOR
AT THE LABOR CENTER HERE TO
PICK EVAN EXPERT THE STANDARDS
AND WHY INDUSTRY POLICY LIKE
THE PLAN MAKES SENSE FOR THE
FLAG THAT. WE RECENTLY RELEASED
THE REPORT ABOUT INTO AND
NINETY IN LOS. STEADFASTLY
DIDN'T AND OVER HAPPEN WORK AND
I. HE'S GOT A DIFFERENT.
DANGEROUS AND LOW WAGE AND THE
CURRENT REGULATORY STRUCTURE IS
APPEALING. M. THOUGHT YOU MEANT
HIGHWAYS THAT INTO HARASSMENT
ACTUALLY. JACKETED WORKERS ARE
QUITE LIKELY THAT WERE GREAT TO
LIVE IN FAMILY WITH IN BELOW
THE FEDERAL LINE. HELLO HAVE
MADE A DIFFERENCE FOR WORKING
TO MEET BASIC NEEDS BUT
EMPLOYERS DON'T HIGH ENOUGH
WAGES WERE TURNED PUBLIC SAFETY
NET PROGRAMS BY AS MY HOW THAT.
COST OF FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
YEAR. OKAY NINETEEN EXACT
EXISTING INEQUITIES EXPERIENCED
FAST FOOD WORKERS WHO ARE 80%
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND 68% BATMAN.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT THE
FRANCHISE MODEL ITSELF
INCENTIVIZES VIOLATION BECAUSE
OF THE RULES AND RESTRAINTS PUT
ON BY THE FRANCHISOR SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS ARE EFFECTIVELY
WE UNABLE TO INCREASE PROFIT
MARGINS THAT WOULD ENABLE
COMPLIANCE. OUR FINDINGS CALLED
FOR A PUBLIC POLICY
INTERVENTIONS THAT LIP
STANDARDS FROM THE GROUND UP
AND INCENTIVIZE COMPLIANCE FROM
THE TOP DOWN. WHAT AND THAT
LEVELS THE PLAYING FIELD BY
PROVIDING WORKERS EMPLOYEES AND
OVERSIGHT OVER THEIR WORK
CONDITIONS AND THREE IS A
FRANCHISE THAT THE APPLE
STANDARD AND IT SURE THAT THEY
HAVE THE RESOURCES THEY NEED TO
DRIVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I
ALSO. HAVE BGH ISM I'M HERE I'M
TOTAL ON THE LINE ON THE
TELEPHONE WHO'S HERE FOR
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS SHOULD THEY
ARISE IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN. SUPPORT OF. AB TWO
FIFTY SEVEN. SEEING NONE ABOUT
THE WITNESS VIDEO REAL. TRY
AGAIN. SORRY NO ZERO IS NOT
ASKING YOU. JUST THE WITNESS
VIDEO ROOM OR THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY SIGHT SEEING NONE
RIGHT OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN
THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO LIKE
TO DECADE SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY
TWO FIFTY SEVEN. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF EIGHT B.
TWO FIVE SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
WILL WATCH LINES SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BERS MITCH
SNIDER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO EXPORT.
THANK YOU I'D ONE HUNDRED
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTER THREE
MONTHS OF OCTOBER ELECTIONS
AROUND LONG PARTY THE PRODIGAL
PORT. THANK YOU I SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS WHEN THEY
BY ARGO ON THE OUTLOOK YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA IN THE FIGHT TO GET
TEAM WE ARE CO SPONSORS AND ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
LINE ONE EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MISTER
TURNER COMMITTEE MEMBERS
JONATHAN PLAN ABOUT THE COUNTY
SAN DIEGO SPORTS. LINE ONE
SIXTEEN GLAD. NINE ONE ONE TWO
CREEK AHEAD. YEAH YOU WILL
FOLLOW. I'VE BEEN ABLE TO WIN
THE SEE IT. NINE TWENTY GO OUT.
BUT THEIR TECHNIQUE TO HELP
SUPPORT THANK YOU. BUT I IN ONE
NIGHT CHANGE THE CLASH.
MICHELLE RIGHT LAST- CRIMINAL
RIGHT. THANK YOU I HAVE BLOCKED
AWAY SHRINK YOUR THIS TIME
RIGHT THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW
THEN MOVED TO OPPOSITION I HAVE
TO OPPOSITION WITNESSES LISTED
ON CARLOS SHIKON AND MAKAYLA
MENDELSSOHN. BOTH WITH US ON
THE TELEPHONE ARE EITHER OF YOU.
HERE. ONE PART OF AN BONUS WITH
MICRO CHICAGO HAVE PLEASE. HI
GOOD MORNING- MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS JUAN CARLOS CHACON I AM
THE PRESIDENT EXTEND DINING
GROUP OF FRENCH IDEA OF CARE
YOU MIKE SUBS AND LOS ANGELES.
WE OWN AND OPERATE SIX
RESTAURANTS. AND NOW LOS
ANGELES AND WE IMPLORE A
ROUGHLY SIXTY FIVE EMPLOYEES.
CALIFORNIANS AB TWENTY SEVEN
WILL DESTROY A SUCCESSFUL MODEL
BUSINESS OWNERSHIP CORRECT
OUTLOOK CALIFORNIA. I AM A
FIRST GENERATION SALVADORAN MY
PARENTS BOTH WERE BORN AND
RAISED IN EL SALVADOR MY
BROTHER WAS BORN AND RAISED UP
A LITTLE. BIT MORE OF THE
UNITED STATES TO GIVE MYSELF MY
BROTHER AND MY SISTER A BETTER
OPPORTUNITY. I STARTED WITH
DOMINO'S PIZZA IN TWO THOUSAND.
AS A REGULAR TEAM MEMBER
STARTING WITH AN OPPORTUNITY I
GREW TO A SYSTEM MANAGER A
GENERAL MANAGER. A DISTRICT
MANAGER A DIRECTOR. AND B. CAN
EVENTUALLY IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVEN. FRANCHISEE I LEFT ALMOST
BEAT THE TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN.
GO UP FOR A BETTER OPPORTUNITY
WHICH MIKE'S FEDERAL JERKING
MIKEY TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN TO
OWN MY OWN BUSINESS TOOK TO GET
MULTIPLE LOCATIONS. WITH THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE TO A BRAND
THAT WOULD SUPPORT ME AND MY
GOALS AND MY DREAMS TO BECOME A
BUSINESS OWNER AND A MULTISTORY
UNIT OPERATOR. I'VE GONE FROM
ONE TO THREE. FIVE SIX. ALL
WITHOUT GIVING OPPORTUNITIES TO
SEVERAL ENTRY LEVEL EMPLOYEES.
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GENERAL MANAGER TO THE REGULAR
ENTRY LEVEL EMPLOYEES TO GENTLE
MANNER JUST TO SUPPORTING THEIR
FAMILY. CREATING ANOTHER INCOME
FOR THEM TO BUY THEIR- THEIR
FIRST HOME. IN THE BUDGET
SUPPORT THEIR FAMILIES. AND ALL
MY OPPORTUNITY WAS THE BE ABLE
TO GIVE THEM THAT SUPPORT.
DURING DURING THE PANDEMIC A
LOT OF US IT WAS ALL NEW WE DID
NOT KNOW WHAT WAS GOING ON AT
THE END RESOURCES SUCH AT PPP
WAS NOT M. AVAILABLE TO WHAT.
THE MEDIA LEE AS A WHAT SCARES
STEVEN HOSPITALS ONCE IT WAS
MADE AVAILABLE WE CALLED ALL AT
CDC AND HEALTH DEPARTMENTS-
REGULATIONS TO KEEP TO ENSURE
THE SAFETY OF ALL MY EMPLOYEES
AND INCLUDING MYSELF. THERE'S
NOT ONE DAY THAT I STOPPED
GOING TO LOCATIONS IN THE
RESTAURANTS TO SUPPORT MY
EMPLOYEES AND THE SERVICE THE
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY AND ALL MY
CUSTOMERS THAT WANTED TO EAT
THERE- RECENT. STATISTICS SHOW
GROWING NUMBERS OF WOMEN AND
MINORITIES OWNING FRANCHISEE
FRANCHISE THAT WAS MEANT. AND
AB TWO FIFTY SEVEN WHAT
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT THE
OWNERSHIP. OF THESE BUSINESSES
AND THE DREAMS OF PEOPLE LIKE
MYSELF TO OWN MY OWN BUSINESS.
IN REALITY AS A FRANCHISEE IAM
THE LOCAL SMALL BUSINESS OWNER
OPERATING UNDER A NATIONAL
BRAND OR IDENTITY SIMILAR TO
OTHER NON FRANCHISED SMALL
BUSINESSES. AS A LOCAL BUSINESS
OWNER IS IN CHARGE OF ALL THE
DAY TO DAY ACTIVITIES INCLUDING
EMPLOYMENT DECISIONS HIRING
FIRING WAGES AND BENEFITS AND
WORKING CONDITIONS IN MY
RESTAURANTS ARE LEFT TO ME. IT
IS THE LOCAL FRANCHISEE WHO
OWNS AND OPERATES YOUR TABLETS
MEANT NOT THE FRANCHISE OR- AB
FIFTY SEVEN WILL IMPOSE- UP. UP
HER FIRST STATE LIABILITY ROLE
ON FRENCH REYES DOORS. THAT
HAVE NO ROLE WHATSOEVER INDIA
TO THE DRAFTING LEGISLATION AND
LOCAL LOCAL LEGISLATION AND
STATE LEGISLATION UNDER AB TWO
FIFTY SEVEN. I COULD BE REDUCED
TO MORE OF A MIDDLE MANAGER
ROLE WITH MY FRANCHISE OR
TAKING A MORE ACTIVE ROLE IN
THE DAY TO DAY OPERATIONS. AND
THAT WOULD BE A GREAT. MIKE
EXCEPT FOR KIDS TO HELP ALBIA
MANAGERS AND EMPLOYEES THAT
WORK FOR ME. I'M NOT COMPLY
WITH EVERY ASPECT OF CALIFORNIA
LAW RELATING TO WAGES BENEFITS
HOURS. WORKING CONDITIONS AND
WORKER AND WORK WORKER SAFETY.
THIS BILL WOULD REDUCE NEEDS
FROM INDEPENDENT BUSINESS OWNER
TO CORPORATE MATT MIDDLE
MANAGER DESTROYING THE VERY
BEST YET I HAVE WORKED SO HARD
TO BUILD AND SO SEVERELY
RESTRICTED THE ABILITY. YOUR
ABILITY OF PEOPLE TO OWN THEIR
OWN SMALL BUSINESS SIR I NEED
YOU I WANTED LEASE. OKAY THE
BILL ALSO CREATES A FAST FOOD
SECTOR COUNCIL WHICH WOULD HAVE
THE AUTHORITY TO YOU TO ISSUE
ENTIRELY NEW AND DIFFERENT
LABOR. LABOR EMPLOYMENT WAGE
AND HOUR AND HEALTH AND SAFETY
STANDARDS THAT APPLY
EXCLUSIVELY TO FAST FOOD CHAIN
THESE ARE DECISIONS I ALREADY
MAKE EVERY DAY AND I AM VERY.
AND ALREADY SUBJECT TO FEDERAL
STATE AND COUNTY LAW. WHY WOULD
A LEGISLATOR GIVE US. GIVE UP
ITS ABILITY TO UNELECTED BOARD
TO MAKE THAT DECISION SIR I
NEED TO WRAP UP PLEASE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. RED
MAKAYLA MENDELSSOHN. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I
AM MCCARTY ELEMENTAL SENSE NAY
TRANSGENDER BUSINESSWOMAN AND
CEO OF POOR WEST CORP A MULTI
UNIT FRANCHISEE PROFILE LOCAL
RESTAURANTS IN THE WESTERN
REGION WE EMPLOY NEARLY TWO
HUNDRED PEOPLE IN OUR
RESTAURANTS AND I AM A LONG
TIME MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION. I ALSO
SIT ON THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS
OF MAYOR GARCETTI'S WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WAS VOTED THE
FACE OF THE PERSON EIGHT FOR
CALIFORNIA AND THE NATIONAL
RESTAURANT INDUSTRIES. I AM
STRONGLY OPPOSED. TO AB TWO
FIVE SEVEN WHICH TARGETS QUICK
SERVICE AND FAST CASUAL
RESTAURANTS UNDER BROWN WITH
THIRTY MORRIS. STORES
NATIONWIDE I TRULY FEEL FOR
THIS EMPLOYEE FROM SAN JOSE WHO
SPOKE EARLIER. ANTILLON
SITUATIONS LIKE THIS THEY
SHOULD TAKE FULL ADVANTAGE OF
OUR FRIENDS AT THE DLPH IS
PROTECTIONS AND THE WORKERS
COMP SYSTEM WHICH IS VERY
STRONG IN CALIFORNIA. I KNOW IN
OUR OWN STORES WE FOLLOW VERY
STRICT COOPER NINETEEN
PROTOCOLS AND TRACED EACH CASE
AND NOT ONE EMPLOYEE. WHO HAD
COVERED NINETEEN WHICH WERE
QUARANTINE PROPERLY- NONE- NO
CASES CAME FROM INFECTIONS
WITHIN OUR RESTAURANTS WELL
FROM THE OUTSIDE. THIS BILL IS
AN ALARMING PROPOSAL TO EMPOWER
NEW UNELECTED BODY THE FAST
FOOD SECTOR COUNCIL ESTABLISHED
BY THE BILL DOES THAT WAGE AND
WORKPLACE REQUIREMENTS FOR
RESTAURANTS. SETTING WAGE
WORKPLACE STANDARDS AS WE KNOW
IS AN AUTHORITY CURRENTLY
RESERVED FOR THE LEGISLATURE
THE FORCE MY COMING FROM THE
APPROPRIATE STATE AND LOCAL ANY
CHARGE FOR DOING SO. AB TWO
FIVE SEVEN INTENSELY HANDS
LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY OVER TO
AFFECTED COUNCIL HAS ZERO
ACCOUNTABILITY TO VOTERS AND
THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO IMPOSE
LABOR EMPLOYMENT POLICIES THAT
SUPERSEDE THOSE BEING MADE BY
ELECTED OFFICIALS. THE OTHER
PORTION DEVELOP TAX RESTAURANT
FRANCHISE MODEL. TURNING THAT
MODEL ON ITS HEAD AB TWO FIVE
SEVEN SIX THOSE TABLETS JOINT
AND SEVERAL LIABILITY OF
FRANCHISE STORES BY COUNTY MAKE
FRENCH RESORTS. THE JOINT
EMPLOYER FRANCHISEES ADVOCATE
IT IS CHANGED ENACT EARLY TO
PICK OWNERS OF THE FRANCHISE
BRANDS THE FRANCHISE STORES
THAT THE TWO OPERATORS OF THE
STORES. NOTHING COULD BE MORE
FALSE IN REALITY FRANCHISED
OFFICES LIKE MINE UP AND DOWN
THE STATE OR LOCALLY OWNED
BUSINESSES LOCALLY ON
BUSINESSES OPERATING UNDER A
NATIONAL BRAND OR IDENTITY AB
TWO FIVE SEVEN RESULT IN ME AND
SO MANY OTHER FRANCHISEES.
LOSING OUR TOP ICONOMI SINCE
THE DAY WAS SENT TO BE
STRIPPING US OF OUR DONE THE
IT'S BUSINESS OWNERS AND MAKING
US BASICALLY. EMPLOYEES FOR
LARGE CORPORATIONS. THE
EXISTING MY FRIEND MOUNT. GAVE
ME THE OPTION TO PUT MY EARNED.
INTO MY FIRST RESTAURANT OVER
THIRTY YEARS AGO. JOINT
LIABILITY WOULD REMOVE FOR
THEIR OWN PROTECTION THE
INCENTIVE FOR FRANCHISE STORES
TO DO BUSINESS WITH ANYONE OF
THE LARGE CORPORATE
CONGLOMERATES. EMPLOYED AT MY
RESTAURANT TO BENEFITTED
GREATLY FROM MY BILLION OPERATE
WITHIN THE EXISTING MODEL AND
THE SUPPORT RECEIVED TO GROW
AND TAKE CARE OF THEIR
FAMILIES- TO MY OWN SUCCESS AS
A TRANSGENDER WOMAN IN THE
FRANCHISE. I'M ABLE TO GIVE
BACK ADVOCATING FOR TRANS AND
NON BINARY INDIVIDUALS IN THE
WORKPLACE. THIS THROUGH MY WORK
WITH THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION AND IS THE FOUNDER
OF TRANCE CAN WORK WHICH
CREATES MODELS FOR TRANSPLANTS
OF WORKPLACES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND ASSIST
CORPORATION AND DIVERSIFYING
THE WORKFORCE. THIS IS THE
FIRST EFFORT OF ITS KIND IN THE
NATION. AS WE ARE ALL AWARE THE
FRENCH RESTAURANT FRANCHISE
MODEL IS ONE MADE UP OF AMAZING
STORIES OPPORTUNITY AND
WONDERFUL REFLECTION OF THE
GREAT DIVERSITY IN OUR STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IN PORTSMOUTH
EXISTING LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT
LAWS IS REALLY THE ISSUE AS
ADVOCATES FOR AB TWO FIVE SEVEN
SAY LET'S PLEASE HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION BECAUSE NEITHER WAVE
SECTOR COUNCIL OR GUIDING OF
THE FRANCHISE MODEL WILL
ADVANCE THESE IMPORTANT CAUSES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO VOTE
NO ON AB TWO FIVE SEVEN THANK
YOU AND. I AM WELCOME ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU. IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWO
FIFTY SEVEN. SEEING NONE WOULD
WHAT THE WITNESS VIDEO ROOM OR
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY SITE. ALL
RIGHT SEEING NONE OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE OPPOSITION TO AB TWO
FIVE SEVEN WILL BE TAKING NAME
AFFILIATION AND OPPOSITION ONLY
NO FURTHER TESTIMONY THANK YOU.
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY TWO FIVE
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WATERLINES
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORE
IMPORTANT THEM- AND I HAD A
PUPPY FONG. THANK YOU ARE RIGHT
ONE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING ASHLEY HOFFMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWO FIVE SEVEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
ARE PRETTY MAY CLOSE THE LINES
AND I'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS THIS KILEY. ALL I SET
ASIDE MY POLICY OBJECTIONS TO
THE BILL IT. IT SEEMS DIFFICULT
FOR THIS TO SURVIVE A COURT
CHALLENGE BASED ON. SORT OF
BEING A SURRENDER OF
LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY SO- I
MIGHT SUGGEST AND EVEN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS- REYES IS
SEEMS TO. REJECT THE RELEASE
RAISES THAT CONCERN. AS I MIGHT
SUGGEST YOU KNOW NARROWING THE
SCOPE OF THE AUTHORITY THAT. IS
GRANTED TO THIS COUNCIL OR
PROVIDING MORE STANDARDS IN THE
LEGISLATION TO PROVIDE GUIDANCE
ON HOW TO IMPLEMENT THE
AUTHORITY. OR MAYBE PROVIDE
SOME SAFEGUARDS FOR-
INDIVIDUALS WHO FEEL LIKE- YOU
KNOW THEY ARE TREATED UNFAIRLY
BY THE COUNCIL- AS PERHAPS YOU
KNOW GIVING IT A BETTER CHANCE.
TO STAND UP TO A COURT
CHALLENGE. THANK YOU YEAH THANK
YOU KNOW WE HAVE A LONG HISTORY
IN CALIFORNIA OBVIOUSLY WITH
INDUSTRIAL WAGE- COMMISSION. OF
ESTABLISHING A SIMILAR TYPE OF
BODY TO. INCREASE IMPACT WAGES
IN CERTAIN INDUSTRIES AND
CHANGE- WAGES. THIS DOES EXPAND
BEYOND THAT I DO UNDERSTAND
THAT BUT IT DOES HAVE THE
SAFEGUARDS THAT ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEDURES ACT SO I THINK AS
THE- AS ANALYSIS POINTS OUT. I
DO BELIEVE THAT PROVIDES ENOUGH
OPPORTUNITY FOR INDIVIDUALS- IN
THE RULE MAKING PROCESS TO
PROVIDE FOR THIS WE WANT TO.
YOU KNOW THIS IS A NEW- A NEW
OPPORTUNITY FOR SECTORIAL-
VOICE OF SUPPORT HELP. PROCESS
RIGHT EVERY TIME WE BRING. A
BILL FORWARD IN THIS IN THIS-
BODY WE HEAR YES BUT- THIS THIS
MIGHT BE A PROBLEM OVER HERE
BUT YOU'RE ALSO AFFECTING THESE
BUSINESSES THAT YOU DIDN'T MEAN
TO THIS WILL TAKE ABOUT
ARGUMENT AWAY BECAUSE WE ARE
SIMPLY. OFFERING A SPACE OF
FAST FOOD RESTAURANTS RIGHT SO
FAST FOOD AND FAST FOOD WORKERS
AND SO I THINK WITH THE- THE
APA AS WELL AS OUR HISTORY IN
CALIFORNIA WITH AYE WC AYE I'M
I'VE- I RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE
BUT I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS
AND- I UNDERSTAND HOW WE COULD
HAVE A DISAGREEMENT ON HOW. ON
HOW THIS PLAYS OUT. THANK YOU
SEE NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS BECAUSE YOU MAY CLOSE.
I YOU KNOW HOW. WE HAVE TO
START SOMEWHERE IT IS NO IT
WOULD BE THE FIRST OF ITS TYPE
AND I WANT TO GIVE KUDOS TO THE
FRANCHISEES WHO SPOKE IN
OPPOSITION I AM NOT SUGGESTING
IN ANY WAY THAT EVERY
FRANCHISEE OR EVEN- EVERY
BUSINESS MISTREATS ITS WORKERS
OR DOESN'T DO THINGS WELL
UNFORTUNATELY A VAST MAJORITY
OF FAST FOOD WORKERS AT AGREE.
THAT THEIR WORKING CONDITIONS
ARE NOT AS DESCRIBED BY THE
FRANCHISEES SO WHILE WE WOULD
LOVE TO HOLD UP THOSE GOOD
ACTORS- THAT WE HEARD TODAY WE
MUST UNFORTUNATELY LEGISLATE ON
BEHALF OF THOSE WHO ARE NOT
SUCH GOOD ACTORS IN EVEN IN THE
SITUATION THAT WE'RE HEARING
FROM THE FRANCHISEES WERE
HEARING FROM THE BUSINESS OWNER
NOT FROM THE WORKERS THIS IS
ABOUT GIVING THE WORKERS A
VOICE ON THE JOB AS WELL. THEY
HAVE NEVER HAD THEIR INPUT
TAKEN IN A WAY THAT FORMALIZED
THAT'S CLEAR THAT PROVIDE
STRUCTURE AND PROTECTION
EMPOWERS THOSE VERY WORKERS WHO
ARE AS WE HEARD FROM FROM THE
WITNESS WORKERS WHO WHO SPENT
DECADES IN THE INDUSTRY SO I
THINK THE TIME HAS COME IF WE
ARE SERIOUS ABOUT GETTING OUT
OF THIS PANDEMIC IN A WAY THAT
THAT REFOCUSES OUR ATTENTION ON
THE INEQUITIES THAT EXISTED
PRIOR TO IT THIS IS THE FIRST
STEP IN THIS INDUSTRY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I ABOUT.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND SECOND THAT MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE HI STONE AYE
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER NO CHAO.
TO DAVIES DAVIES NO AND SALAS
HI SALAS I HOLDEN KALRA. KALRA
KILEY KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN
REYES HI YES I. THAT NEEDS TO
MORE VOTES ON THE PLACE THAT
BILL ON CALL. RIGHT THAT TAKES
US TO ITEM NUMBER THREE AB
FOURTEEN SIXTY SEVEN MS
CONSULTANTS STAND YOU ARE
PRESENTING FOR MR THE CERVANTES
HI SHERRY I'M THING WHICH IS
FINE BUT FOR AUTHORS OUT THERE
IF YOU DON'T LET US KNOW THAT
THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN WE JUST
RECEIVED. WRITTEN NOTIFICATION
FROM THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE ABOUT
TWENTY MINUTES AGO WHICH IS NOT
ADEQUATE FOR US AND YOU RUN THE
RISK OF HAVING YOUR BILL NOT
HEARD OR PASSED OVER ON THE
FILE SO AUTHORS I DO SUGGEST
THAT YOU LET. THE COMMITTEE
KNOW IF SOMEONE ELSE IS GOING
TO BE PRESENTING FOR YOU BUT
SOUTH GO AHEAD PLEASE. YEAH I'M
I'M SORRY I THINK IT WAS A-
UNFORESEEN ILLNESS SO- THAT
BEING SAID THAT. AB FOURTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY WOMAN SERVE ON TESTS I
WANT TO BEGIN BY STATING THAT
SHE WILL WORK. ON THE ISSUES
OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS AND
WORK ON THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
AND HIGHER EDUCATION STAFF AS
WELL AS STAKEHOLDERS AS OR
SHOULD THIS. BILL MOVE ON AND
MOVE FORWARD TO THE PREPARATION
THERE ARE SPECIFIC. AMENDMENTS
THAT ARE LISTED SHE'S TAKING
THOSE AUTHORS AMENDMENT SHE
WILL TAKE. THOSE AMENDMENTS.
OKAY OKAY THANK YOU I WILL TAKE
THOSE COOPER THOSE AMENDMENTS
ON HER BEHALF. OVER RECENT DEBT
DECADES IT'S BEEN CLEAR THAT
THE UNIVERSITIES UNIVERSITIES
NEED TO REEVALUATE THEIR
APPROACH TO SEXUAL ASSAULT AND
SHIFTED TRAUMA CENTERED
POLICIES TO BETTER SERVE THE
NEEDS OF SURVIVORS WHEN THE
MOST IMPORT POLICIES THAT MAKE
SURVIVORS MORE LIKELY TO REPORT
AND FOLLOW THROUGH WITH CHARGES
IN THE PRESENCE OF TRAINED
SEXUAL ASSAULT COUNSELORS ON
CAMPUS. HOWEVER ANY CAMPUS
POLICIES IN THAT SPACE FOCUS ON
COMPLIANCE AND ARE OFTEN AT
ODDS WITH THE SURVIVOR CENTERED
RESPONSE THAT SEXUAL ASSAULT
COUNSELORS PROVIDE THIS MEANS
THAT SEXUAL ASSAULT COUNSELORS
ARE OFTEN FORCED TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN SUPPORTING THE NEEDS OF
SURVIVORS AND COMPLYING WITH
THE CAMPUS POLICIES THAT MAY
NOT PRIORITIZE THOSE NEEDS EVEN
THOUGH THEY MAY BE DOING WHAT
IS IN THE BEST INTEREST OF A
SURVIVOR. A SEXUAL ASSAULT
COUNSELOR MEET FEAR LOSING
THEIR EMPLOYMENT OR FACE
DISCIPLINARY ACTION FOR TAKING
ACTIONS AGAINST THE CAMPUS.
WHEN SCHOOLS MAINTAIN POLICIES
THAT HAMPER THE ABILITY OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT COUNSELOR TO
OPERATE INDEPENDENTLY THEY
ENABLE A CAMPUS CLIMATE THAT
CONDONES SEXUAL VIOLENCE AND
SILENCES SURVIVORS. AB FOURTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN WILL PROVIDE
CLARITY TO SUCH A TO SITUATIONS
BY ESTABLISHING THE SEXUAL
ASSAULT COUNSELORS ARE
INDEPENDENT OF THE CAMPUS TITLE
NINE OFFICE. WOULD ALSO ALLOW
SEXUAL ASSAULT COUNSELORS TO
MAINTAIN CONFIDENTIAL.
CONFIDENTIALITY WITH SURVIVORS
BY ENSURING THE CAMPUS SEXUAL
ASSAULT COUNSELORS HAVE THE
SUPPORT THEY NEED TO DO THEIR
JOB WE WILL ENSURE THAT THEY
WILL TURN. HAVE BETTER TOOLS TO
SUPPORT STUDENT SURVIVORS- WE
HAVE A- WE HAVE TESTIMONY ON
THE LINE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MS
GONZALEZ I DO HAVE ONE SUPPORT
WITNESS LISTED NICOLE BUT ERA.
AN INDIVIDUAL ARE YOU WITH US.
I'M HERE GO AHEAD PLEASE. THANK
GOOD MORNING ARE AFTERNOON
SUPPOSE MY NAME IS A BT THERE
I MEAN DR OKAY AT THE OF IN THE
DEPARTMENT I RESEARCH CAMP
SEXUAL FOR YEARS IN THAT WORK I
SEEN THE IMPORTANCE OF IT AND
THE TO BE FOR HAND. THE ROLE OF
THE VICTIMS TO HELP HER BY I DE
THEIR AND OUT ALL THE FROM THAT
CRUCIALLY THEY CANNOT ARE NOT
TO BRING THEIR OBJECTIVE IN
FACT COME. THERE WILL TO
SUPPORT WHATEVER THE SURVIVOR
TO GIVE THE SURVIVOR CAN BACK
AFTER AWAY THEIR- THIRTY ABOUT
THE DURING THE WELCOME TO
OUTCOME AND HELP SURVIVORS THE
THREE THEY TO IN SCHOOL. W.
DRESSING TODAY'S ARE. VICTIM
ADVOCATE OR FOLLOWING SHE- AND
THAT'S BECAUSE THEY ARE. INTO
ON PAPER THIRTY IS TO AB. FOR
SERVE. BUT IN PRACTICE THERE
ARE DEPEND DID YOU. STILL
TENSION. THE VERY PER OF VICTIM
ADVOCACY. AND MY DISTRICT WORK
THE TEN O'CLOCK MOST OF THE IN
A SURVEY. WANTED TO MAKE RIP.
TO THEM. THE UNIVERSITY I
STUDIED EXCLUSIVELY PROHIBITED
ALL STAFF INCLUDING ADVOCATE
FOR WHAT THEY CALL IT COURAGE
IN REPORT. THE LIST OF THINGS
THAT CAN BE COUNTED AS
ENCOURAGING REPORT INCLUDE
TELLING A SURVIVOR THAT THEIR
EXPERIENCE THAT THE CAMPUS
DEFINITION OF SEXUAL ASSAULT.
OR MAKING INFORMATION. ABOUT
THE RECORDING PROCESS EASILY
AVAILABLE. AND A LOT OF SURVIVE.
WHO ORIGINALLY WANTED REPORTER.
DIDN'T HAVE YOUR- THEY NEEDED
TO DO SO. MANY DRIVERS WHO
BELIEVE THEY HAVE FILED REPORTS
CORRECTLY HAD MADE HIGH EVEN
TAKE THAT UNIVERSITIES
JUSTIFICATION TO IGNORE THEIR
STORY. A VICTIM ADVOCATE COULD
HAVE CORRECTED THESE MISSTEPS
OR BOARD THEM ALL TOGETHER BUT
THEY WEREN'T ALLOWED TO HELP.
INTENTIONALLY ROLLED AWAY FROM
THE CONNECTICUT. THE VICTIM
ADVOCATES IN MY THIRTY HAD
SEVERE PROBLEMS WITH MENTAL
HEALTH INCLUDING SUICIDALITY.
NUMBER FORCED TO QUIT ENACTED
SELF PRESERVATION OTHERS WERE
PUSHED OUT WHEN THEY TRIED TO
BEND THE RULES TO SUPPORT
SURVIVORS AFFECTED LAKE. AS A
RESULT THE VICTIM ADVOCACY
OFFICE BECAME A REVOLVING DOOR
OF STAFF WHO LEFT THEIR
POSITIONS JUST THAT THEY GOT
GOOD AT THEIR JOBS. THE
OPPOSITE TYPICALLY UNDERSTAFFED
AND NEW HIRES WERE
UNDERPREPARED. IT SHOULD BE
OBVIOUS THAT THIS HURTS
SURVIVORS ALL THE RESOURCES
LEGISLATORS TO WORK SO HARD TO
BRING TO CAMPUS ARE OUT OF
REACH WITHOUT A TON OF THE
CONNECTICUT TO NAVIGATE THEM.
THE BILL COULD CHANGE THAT AND
I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT. IT THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK. THANK YOU. I NO OF
WITNESS LISTED. IN SUPPORTERS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO.
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR A BI
FOURTEEN SIXTY SEVEN. SEEING
NONE ABOUT THE WITNESS VIDEO
ROOM WITH THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION. SEEING NONE OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
ANYONE WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB. FOURTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN. IF YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
WE'RE GOING TO LIVE ONE SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE ONE
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AB ONE
FOUR SIX SEVEN. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU I DO NOT HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES LISTED SO
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FOURTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN. SEEING NONE WITNESS
VIDEO ROOM OR THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY SITE. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO INDICATE OPPOSITION TO AB.
FOURTEEN SIXTY SEVEN. IF YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF AB FOURTEEN SIXTY SEVEN.
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. BY ONE TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY
NAME IS CAROLINE STAPLETON I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION FOR WOMEN
THE HOLLYWOOD CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU HOWEVER YOU
MAY CLOSE THE LINES WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. THERE IS
NOT A MOTION YET. THANK YOU WE
DO HAVE A MOTION IS THEIR
SECOND. AND A SECOND. SEEING NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS TO MAKE
LOVE ON BEHALF OF- MISTER OF
ARTISTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. PHONE THANK YOU THIRD
MOTION WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED WITH AUTHORS OF ADMINS
TO APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE AYE. STONE AYE
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER AYE CHAU.
CHIU CHU AYE DAVIES. DAVEY SIDE
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I HOLDEN.
KALRA AYE KALRA AYE KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN IRIS
YES I. THAT BILL IS OUT THANK
YOU MEMBERS ALL RIGHT THAT IS.
EVERYTHING THERE I THINK I'M
GONNA GO I WANNA GO BACK
THROUGH THE AGENDA FOR FOLKS
HERE TO BE ABLE TO ADD ON WE DO
HAVE SEVERAL BILLS ON PAUL
WE'LL START WITH THE CONSENT
AGENDA. CHAU CHIU. CHU I.
HOLDEN MAIENSCHEIN THE- MAIN
CHINA. YEAH. ALL RIGHT I DON'T
KNOW ONE ITEM NUMBER ONE IS OUT
BUT WILL ALLOW THE ABSENT
MEMBERS TO ADD ON THAT IS AB
TEN THIRTY THREE POWER QUE HAN.
CHAU CHIU. CHU I. HOLDEN.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I RAISE
RAISE ACT RIGHT ITEM NUMBER TWO
A. B. SEVEN TWENTY ONE IS ON
CALL THIS IS MR BLOOM'S BILL
I'M GONNA LIFT THE CALL. CHAU
CHIU. CHU I. HOLDEN.
MAIENSCHEIN. OKAY THAT IS ONE
MORE I'M GOING TO REPLACE THE
CALL. I'VE NEVER THREE IS AB
FOURTEEN SIXTY SEVEN CERVANTES
WE JUST DID THAT I THINK WE'RE
OKAY- AB FOR ITEM FOUR IS AB
THREE EIGHTY SIX MISTER
COOPER'S BILL WE DO NOT HAVE A
MOTION. ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO TO
ITEM NUMBER FIVE EIGHTY FIVE
EIGHTY SEVEN. GABRIEL WE THAT.
I'M SORRY. IF YOU LIKE SO THERE
IS A MOTION IS THEIR SECOND.
AND THE SECOND THANK YOU THE
MOST IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE HI STONE AYE
GALLAGHER. CHAU CHIU CHU AYE
DAVIES AYE DAVIES AYE GONZALEZ.
HOLDEN KALRA. KILEY KILEY I'VE
MAIENSCHEIN. RAYOS. THE BILL'S
ON CALL IT NEEDS TO MORE. ALL
RIGHT I'M NUMBER FIVE AB FIVE
EIGHTY SEVEN IS OUT BUT WE WILL
ALLOW MEMBERS THAT AREN'T CHAO
TO. CHU AYE HOLDEN KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN I.
THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER SIX IS ON
CALL AB ONE AB THIRTEEN FORTY
ONE CRISTINA GARCIA WELL IF THE
CALL CHAU CHIU CHU II HOLDEN.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIN CHINA. THE THE
BILL'S UP OKAY THE BILLS OUT
THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB
TWO FIFTY SEVEN GONZALEZ IS ON
CALL IF THE CALL CHAU CHIU. CHU
HI HOLDEN. MAIENSCHEIN. THE
BILL NEEDS ONE MORE SOMEONE TO
REPLACE THE CALL. I ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT IS ON CALL AB TEN EIGHTY
FOUR MR LOW'S BILL I'M GOING TO
LIFT THE CALL CHAU CHIU. CHU I.
HOLDEN MAIENSCHEIN MAIN CHINA.
THE BILLS OUT. I AM NUMBER SIX
NINE IS AB ELEVEN NINETY FOUR
LOW IT IS OUT OF THE COMMITTEE
BUT WILL ALLOW ABSENT MEMBERS
TO ADD ON CHAU CHIU CHU AYE
DAVIES. DAVIES I HOLDEN
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I.
THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER TEN IS AB
TWO FIFTY EIGHT YOUR FOOD WELL.
ALLOW MEMBERS TO IT IF THE BILL
IS OUT BUT WILL ALLOW THEM TO
ADD ON. CHAU. RIGHT CHAU AYE
CHU CHU I HOLDEN MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN NIGHT. OKAY WE
STILL HAVE A FEW MEMBERS TO ADD
ON IF YOU COULD COME TO
COMMITTEE SO WE COULD FINISH
OUR BUSINESS. SO. YES THIS.
OKAY LET'S GO THROUGH THE. THIS
ROAD GOOD LET'S GO TO THE LIST
AGAIN STARTING WITH THE CONSENT
AGENDA. CHECK OUT CHAU AYE
HOLDEN. HOLDEN I OKAY ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB TEN THIRTY THREE
POWER QUE HAN CHOW CHOW I
HOLDEN HOLDEN I ITEM NUMBER TWO
IS ON CALL MR BLOOM'S BILL AB
SEVEN TWENTY ONE ON THE LIST TO
CALL CHAO CHAO HI HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE THE BILL IS OUT ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB FOURTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN CERVANTES CHAU. CHOW I
HOLDEN HOLDEN I. ADAM NUMBER
FOUR IS SB THREE EIGHTY SIX
COOPER IT ON CALL TO LIFT THE
CALL. CHAU CHERUSCI HOLDEN
HOLDEN I KALRA. THE BILL WAS
OUT ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB FIVE
EIGHTY SEVEN GABRIEL. CHAU CHAU
AYE HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE KILEY. A.
B. THIRTEEN FORTY ONE CRISTINA
GARCIA. CHAU CHOW I HOLDEN FIVE
GOLDENEYE. ADAM NUMBER SEVEN AB
TWO FIFTY SEVEN GONZALEZ IS ON
CALL AND LIFT THE CALL. CHAU
CHOW I HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE THE
BILL IS OUT I REMEMBER EIGHT
EIGHTY TEN EIGHTY FOR LOW
QUALITY OF THE MEMBERS. CHAU
HOLDEN HOLDEN I REMEMBER NINE
ELEVEN NINETY FOUR LOW QUALITY
OF THE MEMBERS CHAO CHAO II
HOLDEN. HOLDEN I AND THENI'D
OF NEVER TEN A. B. TWO FIFTY
EIGHT FOR YOUR PUJA CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS HOLDEN.
GOLDENEYE. OKAY I THINK THAT.
IS EVERYTHING. SEEN YEAH. OKAY
YEAH ALL RIGHT GREAT IDEAS OUR
AGENDA FOR TODAY THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH AND WE ARE
ADJOURNMENTS.